et bonjour à tous salut Fatou comment tu
vas
très très bien donc on se retrouve avec
Fatou on se tait pas remis depuis depuis
le tata style ensemble et puis on est là
aujourd'hui pour commenter ensemble le
grand tournoi du Napoléon
enfin trophée Napoléon du coup qui se
déroule à La Roche-sur-Yon
donc c'est un tournoi un petit peu
particulier parce qu'en fait c'est un
tournoi de Blitz avec seulement 4
joueurs donc vous avez en fait donc on
va représenter un petit peu les joueurs
je vais vous montrer un petit peu je
pense que vous avez déjà vu la fiche que
je vous ai montré pendant un petit
moment ici vous avez dans deux grands
maîtres français qui font partie de
l'équipe de France donc on a tiré une
guerre Amiens et Maxime Lagarde
et on a aussi ensuite donc ce féminin
qui est multiple championne de France
ainsi que Eliott Aban Diamantis donc un
jeune ému qui a 16 ans et donc les
quatre joueurs vont en fait se
rencontrer en blitz en 3 + 2 va y avoir
12 parties donc en tout ça fait six
parties chacun mais on verra une à la
fois en fait donc on verra en fait en
tout 12 parties ensemble donc c'est du 3
+ 2 et en plus c'est vrai il y a une
petite nouveauté qui est assez
intéressante je pense qui pimente un
petit peu
ben le jeu d'échec c'est que
les joueurs en fait sont forcés de jouer
la partie avec E4 E5 dame F3 donc je
vais vous montrer un petit peu le
l'échiquier attendez je vais partir sur
celui-là
et donc en fait cette position c'est la
position avec laquelle on va commencer
en fait toutes les parties donc E4 5
d'un F3 donc la très haut noir dans
cette position et on va voir un petit
peu comment comment ça joue donc ici on
sait que les Noirs ont déjà davantage au
deuxième coup parce que 3 c'est pas
c'est pas un très très bon coup et juste
pour l'anecdote qu'on m'a raconté tout à
l'heure en off
en fait ils ont demandé à à tigraine
d'araignée qui joue tendance ce qu'il
pensait du grand miroir donc en miroir
c'est F4 ici et il a dit non mais c'est
pas bon et du coup il dit que Damel 3
c'est intéressant parce que ça empêche
du coup F4 voilà l'anecdote de Tigrane
donc pour la première partie on va voir
ici du coup garamian
mais je vois que sur la caméra c'est
Maxime Lagarde qui est installé
voilà
à dire ça a commencé parce que je vois
non seulement ça va commencer là on a
une position
on les voit comment c'est la partie mais
du coup on n'a pas on n'a pas accès à la
bonne partie en fait
avant que ce soit bien celle-là
ça y est en fait il faut rafraîchir je
pense la page
voilà mais attendez c'est bizarre ça
parce que normalement on commence quand
même avec un
qui me semblait que c'était imposé quand
même 400 est-ce que j'ai des bêtises
c'est comme à faire est-ce qu'on
m'aurait menti parce que il me semblait
que 4,5 dans le F3 était imposé et là je
vois que il y a une Anglaise qui vient
d'être jouée je me dis qu'est-ce qui se
passe
[Rires]
ça va être génial en vrai c'est pour
vous c'est une belle occasion de pouvoir
rencontrer un petit peu
ah c'est ce soir OK
c'est vrai que je pensais que c'était
aussi le cas sur sur les parties
de ce soir
les quatre vont jouer contre 100
personnes
sans personne c'était ouvert les
inscriptions étaient
libres gratuites et il fallait juste
se présenter envoyer un mail ou je ne
sais quoi pour participer et du coup
tout le monde allait aller le noir et
les quatre joueurs sont forcés de jouer
l'ouverture de Napoléon que stock a
montré juste avant
il y a encore 15 places possibles 15
places libres cool
ok
si vous n'êtes pas loin de La
Roche-sur-Yon et ben n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre enfin déjà contacté les
organisateurs et voir s'il y a de la
place pour la simultanée c'est quand
même sympa de pouvoir rencontrer un
petit peu les meilleurs joueurs français
donc là du coup on a on va voir 12
parties les unes après les autres donc
là on a Maxime Lagarde qui est champion
de France
qui joue contre Sophie Millet donc il
doit être bon qui est olympique une des
meilleures joueurs françaises mettre
internationale
comment numéro 3
ça fait très très longtemps qu'elle est
au top niveau donc donc il y a 2400
hello quoi à peu près
donc la partie ce que l'anglaise donc
généralement souvent un ordre avec H5
pour empêcher G4 l'expansion ici
on va un petit peu comment ça se joue
ok donc je viens d'avoir la confirmation
que
attendez
[Musique]
ok ok donc je viens d'avoir la création
qu'on m'avait
pas bien expliqué il y a une petite
confusion donc on joue bien aux échecs
normaux pendant 12 parties et ce sera
les simultanés qui seront avec tout
Napoléon
donc c'est bien ça donc là aujourd'hui
on joue on joue pour l'instant on est
parti normal donc à 3 c'est logique avec
des B4
donc Maxime qui a déjà une minute
d'avance à la pendule
c'est pas mal donc
vous avez quand même toujours un rajout
de temps ici de 2 secondes à chaque fois
donc les gens tombent pas autant
et
[Musique]
mais quand même une minute à cette
annonce là c'est quand même beaucoup
donc faire attention ne pas trop trop se
laisser embarquer dans une on va dire tu
vois
surtout contre un Maxime Lagarde ça peut
être difficile le deck not donc a été
joué qui a l'air à tout à fait tout à
fait bien j'aime beaucoup les Noirs ici
il y a une prise de sang tu vois et au
final les Blancs ont du mal à s'exprimer
au centre tu vois le pion le 4 il
comprend quand même pas mal les cases
grand rock ça c'est un coup à la maxime
c'est un peu surprenant
et là j'ai du mal à les bouger justement
parce que si je bouge le pion des je
vais pouvoir manger là il y a aussi ça
qui tombe il y a un peu tout qui qui se
casse un peu la figure la grande après
avoir joué A3 V3 c'est c'est un peu
bizarre quand même
donc il faut 5 de jouer ici
3 B1 qui est un coup logique j'aime bien
un J5 quand même un choc à un moment
donné ça va être un coup qui va y jouer
peut-être que là
non ça marchera pas avec un B2
intermédiaire et après je pourrais
manger un 4 et souvent à chaque c'est un
coin important pour pouvoir en fait
mettre le fond en F5 sans se prendre G4
après peut-être que du coup maxi
m'attend qu'elle fasse H5 pour faire G4
ils sont ouvrir les colonnes h mais
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on fait Sophie était assez
normal ici j'aime beaucoup les Noirs
franchement c'est le Robinson comment
va-t-il
[Musique]
donc là on peut peut-être voir
comme ça B5 était joué alors j'étais un
peu aseptique par rapport à cavaler ses
cinq peut-être j'ai fout des cinq du
coup juste et
et
du coup le cavalier ici enfin le fou il
y a personne des 5 mais là je suis pas
sûr peut-être que les Blancs ont réussi
à bloquer un peu là
sur le pkura A4
on va bloquer en fait l'attaque
mais toi le fond en deux c'est une très
mauvaise pièce
peut-être penser à ramener la dame aussi
dame là voilà
[Musique]
et même je pense une idée aussi de
mettre la dame en C7 pour faire cavaler
cette fête pas mal
alors attendez bah moi aussi je me
demande robinside et apparemment je
viens d'avoir une contre-indication
encore
et apparemment c'était bien imposé
apparemment bah je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé
parce que du coup normalement moi ce
qu'on m'a dit c'est que E4 5 dame F3
devait être imposé quand j'ai vu
l'anglaise je dis presque qui se passe
c'est un bug et non c'est pas un bug
donc j'ai demandé un petit peu à
la Régie quoi aux gens qui secouent un
petit peu du stream et ils m'ont dit que
apparemment ben ils ont compris comme
moi mais qu'ils ont du mal comprendre
donc ils ont vérifié et apparemment si
je comprends bien je crois que c'est les
joueurs qui sont trompés et qui ont
trouvé cette partie alors qu'il devait
jouer le Napoléon voilà donc c'est bien
les joueurs qui sont au piège quoi
[Musique]
il rappelle bien que aussi pour le
tournoi des joueurs l'ouverture imposée
du coup Maxime qui a joué l'anglaise
avec les Blancs
alors normalement après e403 et ben il
est déjà moins bien au premier coup
donc je sais pas on va voir on va voir
en tout cas
ils ont commencé ouais c'est ça
je commence à bien aimer les blancs en
fait un petit H4 voilà les pions qui
vont avancer là-bas
ça se calme bien pour les Noirs le
Roland qui aime très faible mais bon on
attaque peut arriver ici quand on Blitz
avec très peu de temps à la pendule il
peut passer plein de choses
avec comme on peut jouer ici sur tourner
qui peut arriver et aller manger des
pions faire attention à ça
comment est-ce que je peux continuer ici
une chance de dame
il a tout F2 c'est pas en prison un jour
je retourne
[Musique]
on va dire qu'on rentre de vacances
n'est-ce pas
c'est ça alors tout le sein donc là du
coup clair il y a une heure il y a une
qualité d'avance donc comme la tour ici
on va mettre le roi ici on va monter le
roi et puis un jour on va jouer F3 pour
débloquer un peu la situation au centre
donc ça va ça va gagner je pense
on va sur la caméra que Maxime je tourne
des 4
après je vais voir si je peux vous
agrandir un peu la caméra peut-être vous
mettre que la caméra et pas les chéquier
qui est dans la caméra peut-être sera
mieux comme les Ch'tis vous l'avez déjà
sur cheesecom peut-être que ça prend de
la place pour rien je vais essayer pour
la prochaine partie de vous faire ça
du coup
il a échangé il a maintenant c'est fini
on a plus qu'à pousser le pion virer le
roi
et ça va être
ça va être je pense que c'est facilement
gagnant ça
[Musique]
ils ont joué
en vrai si ils ont laissé jouer moi je
pense qu'ils auraient dû faire c'est que
c'est vraiment il veut annuler tu vois
et ben ils auraient dû annuler au
premier coup quoi enfin au deuxième coup
dès que tu me enfin même au premier dès
que tu joues C4 tu dois annuler mais du
coup voilà si le panier là ils ont
laissé jouer donc tu laisses jouer quoi
tu peux pas une fois que j'ai fini la
partie
annuler maintenant quoi c'est un peu
bizarre
c'est terminé
c'est terminé et abandon de Sophie
Millet victoire de Maxime Lagarde dans
un premier parti
du coup alors si
je regarde bien mon petit
je l'ai pas ici
j'avais ouvert mon petit dossier là
tu le fermer sans faire exprès
le petit programme tu sais
parce qu'on a des parties en fait tous
les quarts d'heure
ouais tous les quarts d'heure du coup
c'est ça je l'ai ici mais je l'avais
déjà en fait non je suis bête je l'ai
retrouvé pas donc voilà partie de sa
trésor 15 donc dans 5 petites minutes on
aura un garamyan avec les Blancs contre
Elliott papa Diamantis
donc pareil donc là on va voir un peu ce
qui se passe est-ce qu'ils vont nous
changer les
[Musique]
est-ce qu'ils vont nous changer les
ouvertures puisque c'est vrai que là on
normalement on aurait dû avoir j'ai bien
compris tout ce qui se passe on aurait
dû à avoir E4 5 d'un F3 qui est
justement l'ouverture Napoléon et donc
c'est une action qui est imposée par le
tournoi il faut commencer comme ça et là
Maxime l'a dit bah non moi je suis je
suis pas Napoléon moi je joue C4 et ils
ont une Anglaise et donc je sais pas si
si ça va être 10 ils vont rectifier le
tir ou pas
parce que pendant ce stream on savait
pas si c'était une erreur de chez nous
une incompréhension c'est eux qui s'est
trompé et je crois que c'est une erreur
qui vient bien de chez eux donc on va
voir en tout cas ce qui se passe mais la
partie là on n'a pas accès au non
malheureusement on n'a pas accès
malheureusement on n'a pas accès au
débriefing on peut le faire nous-même
éventuellement sans écouter ce qui ce
qui se disent
[Musique]
là c'est pas la Coupe du monde
d'échecro
là c'est c'est le tournoi de Napoléon
c'est le trophée Napoléon en fait c'est
un tournoi de 4 joueurs quatre Français
qui vont se jouer pour avoir le grand
trophée Napoléon salut Quentin
donc du coup alors en plus cette liste
je la connais bien avec les Noirs parce
que je la joue aussi
en fait c'est une sorte à la pine si on
regarde bien en fait vous voyez C4 c'est
inversé c'est aussi une Sicilienne un
peu comme 4 c'est 5 vous voyez
E4 c'est 5 c'est 6e bah là c'est C4 E5
c'est blanc avec un temps de plus et sur
l'objet 3 C6 et ben c'est une sorte de
la lapine en fait avec 4
et des cinq d'apprendre des cinq
qui avait laissé deux cavaliers ici
fougères tout ça c'est normal
H320
et Adam G6 et normalement si je dis pas
de bêtises
on doit rapidement jouer
avec H5 comme tout à l'heure je disais
hein
qui vient qui arrive souvent ici pour
aller en B4 et souvent c'est cette des
cinq un peu comme dans la partie
voilà avec le petit courage 5 aussi qui
n'a jamais été joué en fait H5 elle m'a
fait mentir complètement à Sophie
et c'est une partie qui était vraiment
pas mal de la part de Sophie je pense
qu'elle avait l'avantage
et
voyez le roi blanc qui fait qu'on rock
alors qu'en fait ici
ben je suis quand même assez ouvert avec
les Blancs c'est pas forcément terrible
tout ça
mais
ça donne pas trop envie pour les blancs
mais après c'est du Blitz et il faut
être précis que l'eau c'est pas facile
pas facile
donc est-ce qu'à la prochaine partie du
coup
les gens qui s'installe il commence dans
quelques minutes
en tout cas ça notre bien réglé comme
une horloge c'est pour moi c'est hyper
sympa
pour l'instant on n'est pas mal après
une partie peut durer un peu plus loin
que prévu donc
dans ce cas là tu vois
ça va se réquilibrer alors du coup on
est comme ça je vous ai mis la
position on voit que garagène il joue
avec des boules quies
et je vais vous mettre du coup comme je
vous avais promis les chéquiers en grand
je vais essayer de modifier ça
pour que vous ayez
en fait comme on voit déjà oups comme
vous voyez déjà une petite partie
ah je peux pas le couper en fait
bienvenue à tous
c'est parti
je peux pas trop enlever en fait c'est
bizarre
je sais pas si c'est moi qui peut jouer
c'est pas ce qu'on m'avait dit OK
au dernier moment où je ne sais pas
nous avons kiffe à tout
on nous a menti alors attends
je vais changer un petit peu le truc je
sais pas si ça c'est mieux ou pas on va
plus le piquer ce qui est avant mais au
moins on voit les gens un peu en plus
grand
et je pouvais pas trop trop faire mieux
malheureusement
non je pense que c'est mieux ça
c'est très bien comme ça
on les voit un peu mieux
donc du coup ça c'est une Sicilienne
avec
Sylviane rapide avec Full C4 un peu
bizarre ce choix normalement c'est pas
trop trop bien c'est cette position de
l'Italienne on va dire dans la
sicilienne
mais ça transpose dans une position un
peu de espagnol espagnol ou ici avec
aussi ce fou B5 échec et les fou qui
revient en Détroit tous ces petits
petits petites manœuvres qui sont assez
standards
en fait il veut anticiper que le câble
est en prise
petit rock donc il y a plein de coupes
aussi 3 et bien cette fois-ci est bien
dame de
ça un peu technique en fait il laisse
vraiment le choix au noir de se tromper
c'est ça en fait généralement quand tu
es quand tu es
vraiment le grand maître du tournoi là
avec l'expérience il faut essayer de
déposition un petit peu où tu peux
laisser l'adversaire
se tromper c'est quand même de caméra
comme la caméra
devient flou
voilà je la remise en tout va bien
et donc avec les jouets donc là il va
sacrifier un pion pour gagner la part de
foot donc on s'en foutu
[Musique]
des quatre ou un dessin
pas sur ce qui se passait sur sur France
donc faut fuite le pion qui est encore
en prison
bien sûr qui a des prix crocos
bien sûr qu'il y a des prix les joueurs
sont professionnels
le bon coup c'est des 5 en général c'est
la réponse à ces
thématique des 5 pourquoi parce qu'en
fait on veut bloquer un peu les pièces
noires
donc le cavalier qui aura plus de cases
ni en C4 ni en dessin et le fond en B7
qui
qui sera dos au mur alors prise en E5 ça
me surprend un petit peu
mais ok l'idée ça doit être plus tard de
pollution un peu symétrique mais avec
des pièces mieux placées alors ces
quatre a été joué intéressant ce qui
fait
coin intermédiaire
surprise en DS6 il faut prendre des 6
qui va attaquer là et du coup j'aurais
ça et ça en prise pas évident
qu'est-ce qu'on joue c'est ce que je
vous ai
mais il s'est passé quoi attends ça va
un peu vite là
il y a eu une prise sous ses deux pour
pas ouvrir la colonne C et prise tour
bien si je prenais pas moi-même en C4
c'est lui qui prenait ici et plus tard
il avait le pion cette fois qu'elle est
tombée
donc et c'est 5
tu es chaud là
très bon c'est pas une super pièce le
fou c'est de
c'est 5 j'aurais réussi à tuer un peu
ces deux pièces là et quoi elles sont en
vie maintenant les pièces noires
sur 206 avoir
[Musique]
comme ça un petit peu comme genre
comme
[Musique]
dans cette position c'est une sorte de
position de comment ça s'appelle
non bien sûr mais toi tu veux plus
dragon je pense non c'est pas des
positions que tu as tu as souvent ça ok
tu apprends ces trois il y a ça en prise
et ça en prison il faut faire attention
hein
Fatou en tactique elle est redoutable je
peux vous dire une chose c'est qu'ici
est censée pas avoir alors à chaque fois
8 aussi
[Musique]
ne se laisse jamais adopter un jour
peut-être
par mois donc
j'aime bien les noirs
je pense pour défendre les deux et ce
petit pion c'est qu'ils peuvent vraiment
faire peur mais d'un autre côté il y a
aussi la les F5 que 6 qui peut arriver
pas simple c'est compliqué ils ont 20
secondes chacun 30 secondes chacun vous
voyez le temps là
c'est chaud
donc là en plus on va vraiment le bon
garamian qui a un habitué tu es au
niveau
contre un tout jeune
pour prendre un 6
ouais
j'ai l'impression que elle va pas bien
loin la clé noire il veut pousser j'ai
compris on a compris
mais les blancs
qui va tomber là
quand je prends là qu'est-ce qui se
passe peut-être qu'il y a tout mais le
roi il va s'échapper je pense il y a une
finale
un petit peu ce cavalier en deux
fous c'est ça donc là bien sûr pas tout
tu sais quand on a un pion plus
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en finale
on échange les pièces c'est ça
corruption pas souvent tendance à faire
nul
donc avoir là il y a pas de temps passé
non
mais bon le roi blanc est plus avancé
perdre pour
pour Eliott avec les noirs
trois contre deux normalement ça passe
pas
après que peu de temps la pendule peut
se passer plein de choses mais
normalement normalement
à ce niveau là ça connaît ça défend bien
donc là on a un petit délai on voit sur
la caméra ils ont plus de coups que nous
je pense que en fait la vidéo elle est
bien
on a un petit délai de retransmission
donc du coup ça tombe bien que vous
voyez la position
la position
normalement elle est nulle les noirs
doivent essayer d'échanger au maximum
les pions
pas les tours pour l'instant ça dépend
un petit peu ça n'a pas un petit peu
de la position si vous connaissez les si
vous connaissez les vos finales de pions
et vous savez que vous changez les tours
ça peut le faire mais sinon
[Musique]
de plus simple c'est d'échanger des
pions et de garder le roi vers la porte
à Casa promotion des blancs c'est final
elle est complètement nul hein même moi
je la fais nul
mais c'est bien de le dire parce que
c'est pas évident pour tout le monde
on se dit on peut perdre
et forcément oui
il faut rester dehors enfin il faut
laisser le roi vers la promotion
et puis attendre tu attends par contre
là ou c'est fait que oui
[Musique]
parce que tourgé 7 va manger le pion il
s'est fait complètement
complètement arnaqué
c'est la vraie partie c'est la partie on
le voit
il perd le pion G1
6 doit gagner
[Musique]
cette finale qui est très très
facilement nul qui a été qui va être
perdu en fait mais en blitz c'est tout
autre chose en fait c'est vraiment c'est
un jeu où on peut se tromper on est mal
au temps et il faut juste très vite et
même avec des super joueurs comme ça et
ben
en blitz on peut faire des gros erreurs
et là maintenant graven va gagner la
partie alors que en partie lente je
pense qu'Elliott il aurait fait nul
si flottant ça aurait été trop facile
échec
donc là il fait un petit échec pour
gagner un petit peu de temps
abandon de la part de Elliot papa
Diamantis dans cette partie donc oui
alors ici comment on aurait pu faire nul
enfin tout
est-ce qu'on peut on va revenir avant
non
donc jusque-là
c'était très bien
en fait c'est là c'est ici en fait si tu
veux ce qu'il faut faire c'est essayer
de faire en sorte que
qu'on garde ce pion quoi et le problème
c'est qu'il a fait un petit tempo et
qu'après j'ai 5 ce qui se passe c'est
que je vais réussir à manger le pionger
quoi
donc il y a eu 6 tu vois tour là le seul
moyen de défendre le pion c'est de faire
je fais échec et maintenant en fait
quand tu fais un coup comme on regarde
par exemple
car refait échec donc là il y a un petit
réseau de maths
5 et une fois que ton roi et demain il
est parti très loin maintenant je suis
ton G7 et le pion il est un défendable
après c'est un peu technique le temps de
faire War 4 manger le pion etc faut
avoir un peu de technique et savoir
attendre ça va bien progresser dans la
position tranquillement on croisait
trois la tour est parti ma réussite
remplacer un peu les pièces et au final
ben la position ici elle est elle est
finie tu vois depuis en plus roi tour
c'est gagnant
et donc du coup
oui ce qu'il aurait fallu faire à la
place du coup après j'apprendrai la
question de cheesecom
c'est qu'en fait ici il aurait fallu
mettre le roi là je pense
et c'est pas logique du reculer le droit
comme ça vous voyez
si c'est le cas mais chez moi il est
il est bien tu peux crier Robins
je peux baisser le main un petit peu le
mien si vous voulez quand j'ai besoin
je baisse un peu le mien vous me dites
on a juste posé une question
[Musique]
magnifique réponse moi je joue
je joue en compétition enfin je joue
activement depuis 10 ans
donc oui
voilà oui oui elle joue
voilà
de la tactique tout le temps ça touche
tactique
c'est la vie
Berthelot à la caméra donc ce qui
commente la partie en direct il y a nice
il y a Yannick pardon qui a un célèbre
entraîneur
et mettre feed
je crois qu'il a presque autant de
nombres que moi on est pareil je crois
non c'est vrai je crois qu'il a quatre
ou cinq normes comme tout
ouais
et donc du coup je disais tout à l'heure
courage vite on met le roi en fait en
arrière il était en fait c'est que les
blancs peuvent pas progresser parce que
si je fais échec ben je ramène mon roi
et donc ça change rien si la tour vient
ta calcul moi va venir défendre encore
une fois et il peut pas partir avec son
roi parce que dès qu'il monte son roi
genre je pars voilà voilà en fait moi je
vais faire échec échec et en finale tu
as toujours les gens qui voient être en
prise quoi
et on sait en plus que des finales
à base de
tourpions contre tour sans nulle très
très facilement donc là vous avez
d'ailleurs la position de de fil d'or
qui est qui est qui est très connu
qui ont commencé direct bon on va
s'arrêter là parce que car Amiens la
Garde a commencé
dommage j'aurais bien voulu vous montrer
un petit peu la finale de fil d'or
enfin tout c'est une tueuse t'inquiète
pas Ahmed merci beaucoup
non je suis gentille très gentille
on n'est pas là pour ça
on gagne pas de points
[Musique]
pour gagner le tournoi de favori quoi
ces deux grands maîtres de favoris et
ils ont tué de gagner leur partie
la partie d'avant donc du coup c'est
l'opportunité un peu pour les deux
joueurs de prendre un peu une option
dans ce tournoi
et
comment je peux supprimer le message de
routage de luxe
[Musique]
de
caramel en fait ça c'est une pleine
position que qui existe en fait ou
cavalier
à cause de pions prend le 5 et un gros
pion arrière en V3 qui prend jamais
avancer
et maintenant l'idée souvent c'est comme
un cavaler en D4 pour venir ici donc là
faut F6 qui a excessive qui est D4 ça
c'est les potions que je connais bien
il y avait juste une partie comme ça il
y a pas si longtemps que ça quelques-uns
il y a quelques mois moi j'ai battu un
mètre
ça m'arrive des fois
un petit peu toutes les ouvertures
je joue un petit peu tout un petit peu
rien au final
c'était moi la seule battle contre Joe
c'était moi c'était moi il y a fort
longtemps maintenant c'était moi j'ai
perdu mais
il y avait la partie de
[Musique]
de mémoire j'ai pas pu voir la fin de la
seule battle parce que j'ai
donc CBK donc là AB n'a plutôt peut-être
tour franchement c'est pas stupide non
plus hein pour taper sur B6
mais apprends à quand même logique ici
encore bah attends Charles j'ai
l'impression que tu l'as vu quand même
quand tu me dis ça quoi
mais du coup B5 je pense d'être la le
doute qui avait ici Maxime son premier 5
voilà ça fait partie 3 mais là ça va ce
que je peux manger quand même B5 parce
que c'est pas clair voyez si je mange
bien il faut prendre mais j'ai un
clouage
attention
mais dans tous les cas j'ai toujours des
trucs donc là voilà il y a eu ce qu'on
avait dit il y a eu des profs 3
toursiens et là il mange en B5 donc là
je fais manger là mais je peux aussi
jouer trois tranquillement ou alors
juste même enfin tu prends cette roi et
voir ce qui se passe après
c'est un peu dur en fait c'est un peu
loin je comprenais pas comment moi il
vient oui peut-être
avoir là peut-être moins sûr le futur
parce que dans ta ligne à la fin
bon en tout cas il y avait des choses
c'est un blitz donc c'est 3 + 2 je peux
pas trop
[Musique]
perdre une ou deux minutes sur un coup
parce qu'après si on calcule un peu pour
rien
et ben au final on peut être mal au
temps donc la stratégie en fait en 3 + 2
souvent c'est de jouer des bons coups
des coups solides et sans forcément
jouer trop concret tu vois
à partir en scène
c'est un peu dur de de tout en les
meilleures
donc avoir un style un peu efficace ça
veut dire on joue bien on joue solide on
fait des menaces mais on passe pas trop
de temps à réfléchir donc on fait pas
les meilleurs quoi à chaque fois mais on
pose voilà on pose des problèmes mais
voilà quoi
on peut gagner autant bien sûr mais le
but en fait c'est mettre de mettre la
pression adversaire tu vois toujours
vite
et pas pour gagner autant et pour mettre
la pression c'est quand tu as un gros
avantage de temps moi j'aime bien ça là
et ça
le foot C4 ça va pas mal
il y a eu des cinq et sur food et 4 ah
il a mangé d'abord en dessin OK
et donc là il me reste plus de faire
tourner c'est un peu dommage
il y a tigrade qui joue avec les Blancs
sont mieux enfin tout
il y avait le fou
mais pas simplement
récipient un petit peu
un petit pion passé
j'aime bien les blancs mais
ils sont serré la main
il s'en serait la main on a pas vu la
fin de la partie
[Musique]
là où est-ce qu'on a eu un bug
qui va lui aussi se propose nul
ok ok why not
ok on peut déçu je pense que les Blancs
étaient pas mal après des quatre
que Maxime se dit je me sauvegarde
là il a senti que ça tournait un peu
qu'il était pas bien que ça tourne un
petit peu là bien sûr je mange pas ici
je vais faire ta tour à 8
et ce fou au final ben il est là il est
pas forcément si bon que ça tu vois
parce que si bien sûr si je mange là
j'ai un peu passé et là je suis très
bien que blanc mais maintenant ben le
cavalier t'as quand même des quatre et
c'est 5 ce qui veut dire que tout est
bloqué on va discuter blanc
et pendant ce temps là je vais faire un
petit H6 pour m'enlever le mode du
couloir et peut-être amener faire Damas
à deux et c'est de ramener un peu madame
et m'activer donc au final tu sens que
qui peut se passer des choses quand même
tu vois les Noirs à un moment donné
pourrait peut-être prendre l'avantage
avec enfin s'ils arrivent un petit peu à
s'activer mais il y a aussi comme ça et
ça qui est faible sur le long terme
moi aussi je trouve que c'est dommage ok
bon du coup
du coup nul donc on a nos deux leaders
qui se sont neutralisés et maintenant du
coup on va commencer avec la ronde 4 qui
va arriver dans 2 minutes normalement
et on aura du coup pour la rendre 4 donc
le duel on aura
papa Diamantis Elliott contre Sophie
Millet donc je le connais pas encore les
couleurs voilà c'est bien ça c'est
Eliott qu'elle est blanc contre Sophie
et
donc là c'est le duel des deux joueurs
qui ont perdu lors de la première ronde
donc là aussi pareil c'est prendre une
option pour revenir un petit peu sur les
deux joueurs de tête qui ont qui ont un
point et demi sur deux chacun
le classement est où le classement vous
vous l'avez pas forcément ici je peux
vous montrer
je crois que je fasse une phase
technique pour le faire je peux le faire
ça après si vous voulez
mais pour l'instant là on a juste qu'une
seule ronde et demi
chaque joueur ont joué entre une et deux
parties donc pour l'instant le
classement est pas vraiment
significative donc je vais pas vous le
montrer pour l'instant ça servirait pas
à grand chose merci mais je suis parti à
cela
[Musique]
donc ça va vite
donc là vous là vous avez le lien de
musculaire chess si vous voulez vous
avez les résultats du tournoi en direct
et
tout ça
donc allez voir le lien
on a le lien aussi bien sûr en direct
vous avez les résultats donc pour
l'instant on a Maxime Lagarde et
tigraine garamian qui ont un point et
demi sur deux et vous avez Sophie millet
et
Elliott on va Diamantis qui ont 0 sur 1
une seule partie mais la ronde 2 pour
eux va commencer donc on va voir si ce
qui se passe si un joueur qui arrive à
gagner la partie et se rapprocher un
petit peu de Ben studio de leader
donc là on est prêt on voit l'arbitre
l'organe devrait l'organe devrait pardon
qui qui est en train de lancer la partie
alors
on a du temps encore un petit peu donc
Elliott contre Sophie Millet
Sophie double et noir du coup dans ton
instant mais après elle aura plusieurs
fois les blancs affilié donc il y a pas
de souci là-dessus
et
[Musique]
Elliott je crois plutôt il joue à 4
je sais pas
moi je l'avais joué 4
ans donc
je l'ai joué il y a quelques années
c'était un tournoi de Blitz
[Musique]
à
je crois partie de cheveux en Corse
je l'avais joué il y a peut-être du coup
trois quatre ans
[Musique]
donc je pense c'est un genre de 4
alors tiens l'arbitre qui commence
et maintenant il joue plein de tournois
et
bon je sais pas si vous avez suivi un
petit peu l'histoire de Eliot papa
Diamantis
et Linkedin par exemple il avait fait il
avait écrit
il a fait un post pour avoir un sponsor
et il a été vu des plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de fois
et au final il a trouvé plusieurs
sponsors pour l'aider à devenir grand
maître international d'échecs donc du
coup Eliot plein de tournois il
s'entraîne et
il est jeune donc
son répertoire a clairement vachement
évolué depuis qu'on s'est joué ça c'est
clair maintenant maintenant est-ce qu'il
joue au 4 ou pas est-ce qu'il va jouer
des quatre est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il est
capable de pouvoir changer un peu son
répertoire et varier sans on va le voir
tout de suite et Sophie pour Sophie
c'est expérience Sophie Millet qui est
multiple semaine de France qui a 2400
euros depuis qu'elle est né à peu près
donc c'est intéressant en tout cas de
voir ce ces quatre joueurs dans ce
tournoi
bien différent
c'est cool c'est intéressant et puis en
terme de niveau ça se joue carrément on
peut avoir des surprises
donc c'est intéressant oui les joueurs
enfin les deux grands maîtres sont 2600
hello donc c'est quand même c'est quand
même plus fort que les deux autres amis
mais
dans notre côté
le niveau enfin en blitz il peut y avoir
clairement des surprises c'est c'est pas
comme si c'est pas comme si c'était
c'était un jouable quoi j'aurais mis ma
place
on part sur une écossaise avec cavalier
2 ici alors c'est un petit peu un
nouveau coup généralement on joue quand
même plutôt plutôt 5 à la place de jeux
cahiers de
et donc du coup et l'autre qui veut
sortir un peu la théorie pour
pour
gêner un peu son adversaire alors
surprendre
hello Sophie est passé GM
non elle est elle est amie depuis très
très longtemps j'ai un féminin oui mais
c'est pas pareil
quand mettre mixte en France on a comme
Harry
[Musique]
donc là souvent et ben on mange en
dessin quand je petit rock kldf3
c'est les positions assez équilibré
est-ce que là je peux jouer autre chose
que que prise en dessin
ça m'avait l'air bien parce que petit
rock en fait il y a toujours des
histoires avec du du kg 4 même et de la
marche qui peut arriver très vite aussi
et on sait jamais
prise en dessin
qui soit pas connecté ouais bon ça c'est
il faut vraiment que tu aies une raison
valable quoi par exemple des fois un
petit peu trop handicapé le bruit enfin
c'est pas vrai truc qui peuvent mais
sinon là dans ce tournoi et ben je sais
pas si vous avez vu à la caméra et ben
un peu caché quelque part et ben il y a
un commentateur qui a un micro et qui
commente la partie en direct et
effectivement
si vous écoutez ce qu'ils disent ça peut
être gênant quoi
au
donc forcément c'est un peu c'est des
conditions un peu particulières aussi
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont tous des trucs
dans les oreilles c'est ça
c'est ça
et trois normes de Grand Maître qui
encore plus dur à obtenir la Salaman là
c'est un niveau plutôt professionnel
et ça se trouve tranquille s'il vous
plaît qu'avez les B3 ah c'est bizarre
parce que ils ont joué 10 coups tu as
l'impression ils ont plus de temps tous
les deux
et on voit tu vois qu'il se passe plein
de choses dans la partie elle a mangé
tes seins qu'elle a laissé faire cavaler
prend ses cinq je suis pas fan d'avoir
donné la part de fou
c'est le premier titre FM
je dirais que c'est le premier titre
reconnu
vraiment
qu'après il y a d'autres titres
donc cm c'est
quand il va mettre donc quand il va
mettre ça c'est un titre feed
F
pardon excuse-moi non tactique que
j'avais juste raté
4 et d'un project 4
non mais ici la position elle est ok
peut-être même pas mieux pour les noms
pour les blancs si les blancs arrivent à
chasser un peu les pièces il faut il y a
un pion il y a un pion un peu faible en
dessin et je m'en fous peut-être pas mal
ici sur une case comme C5 pour bloquer
un peu le pioncer les blancs sont mieux
aussi clairement mais après c'est pas
non plus
donc le noir peuvent se défendre je
pense si vraiment il joue un il joue un
jeu très très serré très précis mais
sinon ça va
donc oui donc je disais que pour le
titre il y a il y a quand il diamètre
2200 et d'eau
et il y a aussi nm qui est national
master donc là ça existe en chaise comme
le titre nm je pense que vous l'avez
déjà vu quelque part mais en fait en
France ça existe pas
ok
ici
surprend il y aurait 3 tours là mais le
problème de quel étroit c'est qu'à tour
reprend tout intermédiaire échec là haut
et après on va manger ici
[Musique]
comment ça se passe mais en fait
les joueurs ont pas le réclamé forcément
en fait tu vois c'est national master
donc c'est national c'est pas étouffeed
feed c'est Fédération internationale des
échecs donc c'est pas un titre connu par
la suite si tu veux mais après par
rapport à cheesecom ils font des efforts
et ils considère comme comme quitte quoi
tu vois mais normalement c'est un titre
national donc il faut
le quoi le NL
[Musique]
après j'imagine que il faut y aller
tournoi enfin il y a des pays qui
t'autorise ou pas je sais que Italie ils
ont
États-Unis ils ont plein
et après je sais pas trop je sais qu'en
Espagne non mais en Espagne ils ont le
CM et aussi
dans les Pays catalans et ben il y a
aussi le
je me demande si elle est pas tomber
autant
elle a dû oublier oublier le temps
ouais elle est tombée ouais elle est
tombée c'est ça elle est tombée dans une
position où elle avait l'avantage oh non
[Musique]
une position où elle souffre
elle souffre mais bon c'est pas non plus
ouais la tour reprend il faut manger du
roi sinon je la tour je perds le pion
des 5 et une fois que je fais ça que je
bouge ma tour
et puis bon ben c'est elle est un peu en
souffrance parce que je pense qu'ici il
y a que les Blancs qui m'avait de
pousser un peu ramener le roi un petit
peu avant d'être à faire à trois tours
c'est deux
mais bon
ça va
time elle a perdu autant elle voyait les
risques c'est 3 + 2 3 + 2
quand on est sur l'ordinateur on a
vraiment tendance à à très peu tomber en
plus dedans parce qu'on va falloir c'est
facile à jouer les coups par contre
quand on est sur un échiquier et bien il
faut jouer la pièce appuyer sur la
pendule et au final ça prend beaucoup
plus de temps en fait sur un vrai
chéquier et en sous-estime un petit peu
la vitesse à laquelle ça passe
le temps passe quoi et du coup Sophie
qui a perdu sa partie autant après un
homme c'est aussi Manu sur le National
et pas fidèle par exemple plus de ça
ah ok et je pense que 2002
USCF
c'est vachement gonflé par rapport au
feed je pense parce que plein de fois je
compte des lois qui ont par exemple 2400
feed et qui ont 2550
USCF par exemple
ça j'ai eu plein de fois je pense qu'il
a assez gonflé aux USA peut-être 150 200
points au-dessus de ton vrai classement
je crois
du coup il y a beaucoup de titres
[Musique]
nm voilà c'est pas un titre connu par la
feed c'est à dire que si vous voulez
faire un tournoi pour avoir des normes
de maître grand maître et que vous jouez
contre contre un nm et malheureusement
c'est pas un genre qui trait
pour chaise comme ça
pour un pour la feed ce n'est pas un
genre qui trait donc bien fait attention
le CM donc c'est quand hydamètre ça
c'est un titre qui est reconnu par la
fuite parce qu'en fait c'est un titre
feed si vous voulez mais par contre
quand vous jouez un tournoi énorme
pareil et ben il faut jouer un certain
nombre de gens qui traits
et en fait du coup
ben le CM ne rentre pas dans les dans
les dans le quota si vous voulez les
gens qui donc c'est un détrait mais qui
ne va pas en fait qui ne compte pas
après le CM moi je le vois plus comme en
France par exemple j'avais déjà vu des
joueurs qui qui avec leur entreprise
avait des avantages quand il se disait
un petit peu joueur professionnel ou
genre ce livre professionnel et du coup
le fait d'avoir un titre international
ça leur permet de prendre plus de congés
et de pouvoir faire les tournois etc et
du coup quand tu as 2200 hello et que tu
veux faire un peu d'échec en plus c'est
que ton entreprise et ben elle comprend
que tu es titré tu vois ça aide en fait
j'avais lu un petit peu comme ça après
dans d'autres pays c'est quand même plus
honorifique mais en France il y a quand
un pays
bien développé et même niveau échiquier
on est quand même
une nation quand même assez forte et
j'aurais de 1200 il a quand même
beaucoup
et du coup le titre cm en France c'est
plutôt enfin c'est pas un truc que les
gens vont prendre quoi on a très peu en
France alors dans d'autres pays vous
allez en Afrique vous allez
souvent aussi dans les pays d’un
mécatine et ben vous verrez beaucoup
plus de CM que ici en fait parce que
pour eux c'est un titre et c'est cool
quoi voilà donc je pense ça dépend un
petit peu aussi de chaque pays et voilà
il y a pas besoin de titres particuliers
pour faire des normes des tournois
énormes
mais il faut que tu sois enfin pour que
tu comptes comme un titré
un homme imaginons moi je suis parti
très et je veux faire un tournoi il faut
que je joue en tout contre 5 titres donc
5 petits traits donc sur 9 parties il
faut que je monte 5 joueurs qui ont des
titres donc par exemple si je joue
5 mètres ben ça marche par contre si je
5 quand il va mettre ça marche pas du
tout
parce qu'en fait cinq candidats ça me
compte comme comme zéro si tu veux quoi
parce que pour la pour faire des normes
il faut le démettre feed de mettre des
grands maîtres
il y a pas une tradition de payer le
titre de ces mains proches
si d'ailleurs moi j'ai plusieurs amis
qui ont été menacés très très fort
mais au final non
je crois que maintenant la fédé a
compris que
qui ferait ça mais je connais plusieurs
personnes en français qui ont ce titre
là un peu parce que il y a un pote à eux
qui leur ont payé le titre dans dans son
dos
et
pas du troll mais là c'est là c'est un
autre homme du coup ça peut être forcé à
te bouger un peu les fesses pour passer
mettre le fil pour plus avoir ce titre
là donc c'est la seule façon
positif
50 euros pour toi ça te fait rien et au
final l'autre c'est la vie quoi
c'est bien rentabilisé quand même 150
euros de troll
t'inscrire à toi énorme quand 2002 quand
tu es 1200
norme généralement sans vouloir fermer
du coup quand on va fermer c'est du coup
un tournoi qui réservait à 10 personnes
et il faut un élo une moyenne des lot on
va dire à peu près 2200 2300 euros donc
c'est un 1200 et d'eau dans le tournoi
normalement ils vont ils vont te ils
vont ils vont te refuser
salut eru
sur le serpentier oui tu as le
tu les as je crois sur
apprendre les échecs
j'en doute
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est
je crois que c'est je crois que c'est
sûr qu'on les échecs je suis pas sûr en
fait
parce que je pense que pour les échecs
qui sont comme nous en fait je crois
qu'ils sont comme nous
il doit avoir peut-être les mêmes
les mêmes
c'est parce que c'est bien ce que je
disais ouais
c'est bien ce que je pensais donc du
coup c'est Yannick Berthelot qui doit
retransmettre là-dessus
allez donc la partie Maxime la garde qui
est commencé donc Maxime qui joue avec
les Blancs contre Eliott et les hot qui
vient de battre Marie Marie Sebag qui
vient de battre Sophie
du coup avec les Blancs donc on a encore
une fois une Anglaise de la part de
Maxime
quelques secondes pour pour inviter ceux
qui sont sur le live YouTube à
s'abonner qu'il le souhaite et on se
demandait aussi pourquoi pourquoi se
finir porter un casque on m'a répondu
mais je sais pas si on a répondu avant
que la question soit posée donc on peut
le répéter c'est c'est ils sont dans un
auditorium avec des gens qui commentent
à côté et du public donc en fait ils
doivent s'isoler du bruit
tout simplement voilà on a deux
commentateurs qui parlent en même temps
et du coup si vous commentez en même
temps qu'il enfin si vous jouez en même
temps que quelqu'un commande la partie
en direct et que vous m'entendez ça peut
vous déranger ça peut voilà
donc du coup les joueurs ont tous des
écouteurs ou des boules Quies etc pour
pas être dérangé
et ouais donc là on parlait de YouTube
donc oui donc il y a plein de gens en
fait qui regardent sur Youtube beaucoup
beaucoup et nos stats en fait nous
disent que il y a 71 % des gens qui sont
sur Youtube qui nous regardent et bien
qui ne sont pas abonnés à la chaîne donc
du coup
je vais vous dire le slogan qu'on m'a
donné hier c'est
ça ne vous coûte rien et ça nous
soutient voilà donc n'hésitez pas en
tout cas ouais c'est bon c'est Made in
l'attente
pour le stream c'est ça non mais en vrai
c'est vrai que ça vous coûte rien de
vous abonner sur Youtube et et puis vous
comme ça vous perdrez pas une miette de
nos futurs événements et tout donc ça
c'est cool
bon nous rejoindre ici on a tous accès
au chat en direct sur twitch sur le chat
moi je regarde uniquement le chat de
twitch s'il y a des commentaires sur
Youtube pertinents venez sur cheesecom
voilà sur twitch pardon n'importe quoi
venez oui je dis pertinent parce que
tout à l'heure tu m'as fait un petit
résumé de ce qui pouvait se passer
donc du coup voilà venez en tout cas sur
twitch venez nous soutenir aussi twitch
nous follow encore une fois c'est
gratuit et puis comment je fais un rime
avec follow
et c'est beau
le flow voilà
donc voilà là je suis un poète je suis
aujourd'hui je suis en forme
je suis rentré de vacances
je suis rentré chez moi [__] je te
raconte pas salut
ou un GM qui fait le slogan
il est pas grand maître
mais il est
comment je peux le troll
comment est-ce que je peux le troll
à faire en personne
en vrai il me l'a fait sans faire exprès
mais c'était assez marrant j'ai bien
rigolé
et ta maman niveau blague il est en plus
il est à fond un petit peu
[Musique]
la dernière parce que
donc un peu plus pour les blancs mais il
y a plein de pions qui sont en prise un
petit peu là c'est assez compliqué il y
a fout des quatre en l'air
et il y a aussi les pions ici en prise
et le cavalier en prise
ça fait quand même beaucoup beaucoup
d'entreprise
F5
[Musique]
normalement oui ouverture imposée avec
le 4 5 dans F3 apparemment c'est pour ça
cette édition ça n'a pas été imposé
alors en fait c'était affiché comme
imposé et on a eu la surprise nous même
à la première ronde que
que
je sais pas si vu que la première partie
a été différente ils ont décidé de
changer s'ils ont décidé de changer
avant parce que ça va quand même été
annoncé effectivement c'est la troisième
édition et normalement c'est imposé
c'est le principe un peu de ce trophée
spécial c'est ça
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
il a mangé
un jour
mesdames F3
apparemment Jean-Michel
non non
cavalier chèque cavalier prend ici
je vais bien plutôt manger du chou parce
que j'ai l'impression que mon roi était
mieux cette camin
l'impression que défendre tout ça
qui progresse un petit peu attention à
chaque gamin et chaque roi là je passe
encore des choses
pas peur
[Musique]
ouais ah en fait à la fin tu rajoutes au
référent peut-être ok en fait je sors ça
tu mets la tour où tu veux
et sur ça tu manges là en fait et sur ça
je vais avoir ça c'est pour ça en fait
que ça marche pas mais j'ai 50 ans bon
c'est pas trop ce qu'on a raté il y a
pas il faut dommage on va bien aimer
voir ce qui se passait sans faute de
et prise prise maintenant notre tour qui
va rentrer le cadet qui va rentrer aussi
voilà peut-être juste pour ces quatre
les petits soucis autant non
pas bien à voir le temps là il est pas
assez grand chez nous
cavalier
sur roi ici il y a tout échec
abandon et abandon de
d'Elliott Maxime qui prend une belle
option avec avec cette victoire
voyons encore une fois il avait une
position qui était tenable mais mec le
temps il s'est fait retourner
complètement et ça
non mais ça montre bien encore une fois
que que le jackpot c'est c'est dur et
que à cette cadence il faut vraiment
essayer d'aller vite et
pas se laisser malmener autant quoi
parce que dès que tu es mal au temps en
fait contre un joueur comme Maxime
Lagarde c'est un cauchemar quoi parce
qu'à chaque coup c'est une peau de
banane et
bah tu peux te tromper au final c'est
dur
mais là faut prendre c'était que ça
avait l'air qu'un plus logique pour pas
laisser le roi enfin pour garder le roi
en fait ici quoi
bon je pense que ça transpose un petit
peu dans la dans la partie quoi
sauf que le roi qui aime mieux placé ici
on le sait quand est fuite ça me pose un
peu problème
et après mettre le fou ici mettre le
four là ou là je pense que les Noirs
pouvaient peut-être des fois plus
facilement
mais bon en blitz c'est c'est très dur
prendre des décisions à chaque fois très
très vite c'est quand même pas évident
[Musique]
vous préférez quoi parce qu'en fait là
quand il y a les quand il y a les
commentaires et ben on voit pas bien les
joueurs en fait
je pourrais vous remettre l'autre vue
parce que vous voulez mais on voit un
peu en plus petit quoi
malheureusement je peux pas
je peux pas faire beaucoup
[Musique]
beaucoup mieux
voilà je voulais remise en normal
un peu plus grand
changé la règle et cette ouverture ne
sera posée qu'elle a simultanésien de ce
soir à 4 contre temps
merci fabuleuse 85
pour pour la précision OK
donc je sais pas quand ça a été changé
mais ça a été changé et on rappelle la
simultané il restait 15 places il y a
une heure et demie je sais pas si c'est
encore le cas
donc il y en a qui sont dans les
environs de La Roche-sur-Yon et
du de l'auditorium
où ça se passe
n'hésitez pas à peut-être contacter les
organisateurs pour participer
alors l'occasion de pouvoir jouer contre
les meilleurs joueurs français c'est
vraiment intéressant là vous êtes quand
même deux des meilleurs joueurs français
donc Maxime Lagarde
vous avez une des meilleurs jours
française se fait minier et un des plus
jeunes espoirs français
Elliot n'a pas Diamantis donc en vrai ça
intéressant c'est cool si vous êtes par
là-bas proche de La Roche-sur-Yon les
gars il y a encore 15 places disponibles
pour la simultanée donc rapprochez-vous
vite de des organisateurs et essayer de
voir si s'il y a une petite place pour
jouer contre contre un de ces joueurs un
de vos idoles
la simultané à 19 heures
que je m'amuse
c'est ça c'est ça
ok du coup alors on a encore 5 petites
minutes avant la prochaine partie qui va
du coup opposer Sophie Millet enfin avec
les Blancs
contre Tigrane garamian donc Sophie qui
pour l'instant à zéro sur deux qui a
perdu deux fois avec le noir donc elle a
eu une fois contre Maxime Lagarde avec
une très bonne position et une autre
fois contre Eliott papa diamantise avec
une position intéressante ou à la part
du temps malheureusement donc
donc voilà est-ce que Fatou toi tu as
des favoris donc ce tournoi
ils sont quatre donc
j'ai essayé de grandir trop
j'ai envie de dire un peu là peut-être
un peu bêtement c'est je trouve ça plus
intéressant si Eliott ou Sophie
gagne qu'ils ont déjà un peu plus
gros en face donc
ça me plairait plus mais bon c'est pas
évident et on a vu les les favoris
prennent la tête
donc ça va être compliqué ça va être
très compliqué
bien sûr
si tu devais nous donner un petit
j'ai pas de faire un peu un classement
qu'est-ce que tu proposerais comme
classement sur le cadre première
[Musique]
et Maxime qui grade
et après en fait ça joue pas tout de
suite il va y avoir une deuxième partie
le premier enfin les deux premiers vont
jouer et les deux autres vont jouer donc
là même si Sophie billet
[Musique]
Perla elle peut peut-être aussi
retourner les choses dans la deuxième
phase
en fait c'est que même si imagine bon ça
n'arrivera pas même si
Sophie faisait 0 sur 6 et Ben
et ben
elle pourrait quand même arriver
troisième parce qu'en fait à la fin il y
aura 12 parties mais chaque jour en tout
on joue 6 et au bout des six parties en
fait et ben ils prennent les deux
meilleures pour jouer les bah le
départage on va dire pour la première
place la deuxième place et ensuite donc
en deux parties et ensuite quand vous
avez les troisièmes et quatrième qui
vont aussi se jouer pour la troisième
place donc du coup même si tu es un
petit peu en retard sur sur le troisième
son troisième et bah tu peux tout
refaire lors des playoffs
donc du coup c'est intéressant
donc une fois que tu es largué tu peux
en fait je suis tranquille
parce qu'on avait c'est ce qu'on avait
moi j'ai demandé
spécialement c'était important qu'il y
ait 5 U et non pas 4 ici
[Musique]
un peu moins où je sais pas si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
donc il faut vraiment que ça soit un bon
ou quoi voilà
qui est ton opinion sur la physique
quantique en général Fatou
après
ouais super
mais finalement ça sera pas le cas pour
pour
le tournoi sera juste le cas pour les
simultanés qui auront lieu à partir de
19 heures
donc là ils sont libres ils sont libres
de respecter ou non les principes
d'ouverture
c'est 5 ici est assez assez logique on
va changer les pions sans trop
et après comme dans un Benco je voulais
contre le pion B2 ça peut être une des
idées ici des noirs
enfin stream quantique sur Youtube et
twitch
d'ailleurs ceux qui sont sur sur Youtube
n'hésitez pas à venir nous rejoindre en
tout cas sur le chat de twitch parce que
moi je ne lis pas YouTube
malheureusement et ceux qui sont sur
Youtube aussi n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à la chaîne c'est gratuit
ça ne coûte rien ça nous soutient
ah je suis hyper content
mais c'est vrai en plus c'est gratuit et
même sur sur twitch ceux qui sont pas
follow ceux qui font le pas la chaîne
vous serez pas averti de tout ce qu'on
fait sur chiascom et faire
[Rires]
[Musique]
plusieurs coins intéressants il y a tout
un aussi peut-être la prise j'aime moins
parce que cavalier en C5 il a des cases
et c'est pour ça que je mets pas trop
trop mon genre c'est 5 pour pas amener
point tu vas inviter ce cavalier sur ces
belles cases
[Musique]
qui attaque B2 c'est un peu comme un
Benco au final tu vois il y a un
problème sur le pion donc faut voir
comment ça tient pourquoi cette mise en
scène pour la retransmission c'est sur
une tablette de téléphone on voit très
mal les pièces sur les cases noires
[Musique]
tu parles de la caméra ou tu parles de
notre échiquier filcas parce que moi
j'ai pas la main sur la caméra il a vu
je trouve qu'elle est pas mal mais même
c'est un peu petit
et sinon sur nos pièces nous ben c'est
des pièces qui
qu'on a ici notre chéquier bah je sais
pas
parce que chez moi je vois bien et même
sur mon téléphone je vois bien aussi
donc je sais pas faire
si c'est toi mais ça c'est des couleurs
enfin c'est basique de cheesecum donc
normalement
en plus c'est meilleur ah oui bleu
concret
Napoléon il sera pas content
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est ça salut à toi apprendre les
échecs je ne sais pas qui se trouve sur
le pseudo actuellement mais bienvenue à
toi et oui effectivement comme on
l'avait déjà expliqué avant les joueurs
ont des ont des boules Quies sont des
casques pour ne pas écouter les
commentaires en direct de Yannick
Berthelot que vous avez auteur la caméra
et du coup voilà ça tombe un peu spécial
les joueurs sont dans nos notorium et du
coup ben s'ils ont pas de casque et ben
ils vont juste entendre tout ce qui se
passe le public les commentaires bon ça
serait un jouable donc du coup là au
moins les gens sont tranquilles et ils
peuvent je leur parti et être concentré
ça donc c'est pour ça que
l'acceptionnellement et ben ils ont
droit aux oreillettes
donc là on va Sophie qui est quand même
très mal au temps qui a 20 secondes
contre une minute 24
c'est ce qui ressort le problème de
temps
bah oui non mais là depuis le début en
plus elle a déjà perdu une partie autant
donc il faut qu'elle
accélère un petit peu
[Musique]
alors du coup ouais mais les blancs sont
pas bien depuis le début tu vois que le
il y avait le pion BD en un peu sous
pression qui maintenant est parti en C3
et au final il y aura toujours un
problème quand même tu vois sur le long
terme les Blancs ont quand même une
position assez problématique et ce pion
ici donc peut-être un petit fou des 3 x
4 alors pas mal et mettre la pression
sur le long terme sur l'option C3 ça
peut être vraiment des vraiment
[Musique]
problématique
en fait il faudrait réussir à tout
échanger arriver en finale pour place il
puisse prendre la valeur mais mettons
que c'est pas fait
c'est compliqué il faut le tenir
bon là on voit les coups arriver un peu
en
paquet
parce que ça joue très vite donc c'est
le temps de septembre
et donc là c'est plus en plus paire de
fou ça a l'air ça a l'air gagnant c'est
facilement
là vous avez quand même deux échiquiers
à voir avec aussi avec aussi les caméras
en direct
pour C7
j'ai l'impression qu'il s'est fait un
petit peu retourné
bon en fait il mate donc je dis un peu
n'importe quoi mais il s'est passé
quelque chose quand même
ok alors ça a été gagné par
du coup si grave alors je sais pas c'est
quoi attendez parce que là il s'est
passé plein de choses
en fait les coups les couilles vraiment
au paquet donc c'est difficile c'est que
avec le retransmission et ben on a on a
un petit peu de délai et souvent ben on
est là on attend et on a cinq coups
d'Afrique qui arrive et ça va trop vite
du coup on arrive pas à malheureusement
à avoir ce direct donc tour à 8 fois F8
fois 4 F5 a été joué full
et maintenant Marie elle a laissé enfin
il a laissé jouer vite donc il y a eu
pour ces 7 foncé 8 et maintenant il y a
le pion ce qui va tomber quoi un
problème
je peux pas jouer je peux pas le
défendre parce que c'est 4 j'aurais
cavalé français 4 suivi
donc du coup j'ai 6
faut prendre un 6 3 G7
F4
ouais 4 c'est le faux bon coup
faut beaucoup qui avait l'air de
stabiliser
F4
[Musique]
fous c'est 5 qui est là c'est trop dur
trop dur si je mets le roi je vais être
matte avec fou ici et tu reprends H2 ça
va être matte sûrement et ici c'est fou
de kiffer qui a fait mat dans quelques
coups avec fougères sur ça je
m'attendais un coup et sur voilà je dois
avoir
comment je m'adapte d'ailleurs Fatou ici
je sais pas faire tu veux que je te
montre
super comment
comme je suis gentil je vais prendre
vraiment en compte les critiques de
filcas et je vais changer un peu
l'échiquier par contre
par contre je vais pas mettre ce que ce
qu'il voulait alors pas de bleu ça c'est
hors de question mais je vais quand même
faire un truc
ça c'est à cause de jazz come fr encore
qui se cache derrière Nathan
face à cause de lui je suis grâce à lui
au fait qu'il m'a quand même trouvé une
solution pour c'est un temps j'ai un
merci merci rassatou enfin tout à
trouver c'est comme ça
allez je vais
actualiser et là du coup maintenant vous
avez un vous êtes de nouvelles pièces
qui viennent d'arriver est-ce que du
coup notre ami Phileas peut nous dire si
ça va mieux
est-ce que vous préférez ce que je suis
là en termes de pièces avec là on va
vraiment c'est plus noir plus noir que
tout à l'heure
là c'est beau voilà
non c'est bien donc là vraiment on fait
notre mieux pour que le stream soit le
plus beau possible
donc là on vient de terminer la rendre 6
donc c'est la moitié on va dire de la
première partie donc pour l'instant
après du coup si onde
donc trois en fait chacun
bien sûr apprendre les déchets
bien sûr
[Musique]
sur la pose elle est à elle est à 4h il
me semble il me semble
regarder le petit le petit truc là
du coup donc oui on a max Lagarde du
coup qui a deux points et demi sur trois
avec garamian qui ose 2 points donc les
deux joueurs qui sont en tête tous les
deux on a papa Diamantis qui a un point
et Sophie qui pour l'instant à zéro donc
là c'est la première on va dire partie
d'événements maintenant les gens vont
toujours avec les mêmes couleurs enfin
bon ils vont avoir les mêmes adversaires
mais changer les couleurs pardon et dès
la ronde 7 on va avoir du coup
maintenant c'est fini avec les Blancs
contre macrim Lagarde donc tout à
l'heure elle avait eu les Noirs
maintenant elle aura les blancs
et
donc partir en revanche
pour fêter le trophée Napoléon à tous
les acteurs sont pas sur les finales de
pions
ah cool
cool normalement
ce qu'ils font
franchement
merci à tous en tout cas
et
[Musique]
OK
pour tous ceux qui s'inscrit dans les 10
minutes qui viennent pas que sera offert
yes les gars vous avez 10 minutes pour
aller acheter le petit pack sur des
finales de pions enfin elle a acheté
pour vous le procurer c'est gratuitement
voilà c'est comme YouTube vous abonner
gratuitement sur sur twitch vous follow
ouais gratuitement et là encore une fois
vous achetez les packs sur les finales
de pion gratuitement tout est gratuit en
fait aujourd'hui
ça y est tout est gratuit
c'est tout voilà mais bon en fait il
faut savoir quand même que que quelqu'un
dans les échecs c'est qui a déjà le
champion de France qui fait partie de
l'équipe olympique donc un cours gratuit
sur fin de pions particulièrement
c'est quand même quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est quand même grande valeur quoi et
donc avoir des vidéos consacrées
gratuites franchement les gars ne perdez
pas de temps et aller vous procurer ce
petit cadeau en tout cas
je vous invite tous à le faire vous avez
que 10 minutes
et donc la partie nous qui va reprendre
dans 2 minutes normalement donc avec
Sophie Millet contre Maxime Lagarde
Sophie blanc donc Sophie tout à l'heure
on l'a vu jouer avec les Blancs
[Musique]
Maxime qui est d'humeur aujourd'hui à
jouer l'anglaise
et bienvenue aux arrivants
et tous les autres même si vous bienvenu
bonjour à vous yes bienvenue à tous
n'hésitez pas à nous expliquer le chat
pour nous dire bonjour
et puis si vous avez quoi que ce soit
d'ailleurs des questions ou des choses
par rapport aux parties au tournoi ou
quoi que ce soit n'hésitez pas à nous
solliciter que ce soit sur YouTube sur
twitch un peu de partout bonne nuit surf
comment
ça va quand même très très vite
donc c'est un petit peu c'est un petit
peu difficile notamment quand les coups
arrivent en paquet mais s'il y a des
trucs aussi couleur au revoir
en petite analyse à la fin de la partie
n'hésitez pas donc toute question on
prend on est là pour ça
à tous
excellente question c'est là dame noire
j'ai un collier de Dame noire
une sorcière merci c'est vrai j'en ai
l'air
j'ai tout pour
et toi Nathan quelle est ta pièce
préférée et toi
moi je vais faire comme Fisher
[Musique]
e blanche
OK
[Musique]
je pense que tu auras les Noirs quand
même le mien je pense tu auras les Noirs
parce que si tu commences déjà
tu commences déjà et qu'en plus
en fait il faut savoir que après
déjà donc si vous commencez avec les
blancs avec un désavantage c'est une
année c'est pas cool quoi non vous aurez
les noirs
parmi vous qui ont déjà eu l'occasion
d'en faire mais c'est quand même des
bons moments c'est spécial fait partie
des choses un peu spéciales aux échecs
ça permet de rencontrer des gens même si
on n'a pas trop l'occasion de leur
parler
des forts donc c'est sympa
on fait au moins une fois je recommande
en tant que en tant que joueur
j'avais failli j'avais failli enfin
j'avais failli
sélectionné encore s'il y avait il y
avait Raja bof il y avait même il y
avait
un an des un autre choix peut-être je
sais plus il y avait 4 joueurs du Top 10
à l'époque qui devait simultané et
j'avais pas été
j'avais pas été sélectionné
je crois que je vais participer à une
simultanée de ma vie
j'avais pu j'ai failli jouer contre
contre Karpov en simultané
à Menton et apparemment menton et il a
dit que je trouve
trop fort et qui voulait pas que je joue
j'étais fâché j'étais Nicolas je voulais
pleurer en plus j'étais pas fort 2002 tu
vois
là maintenant je me réflexe tu vois sur
le simultané mais bon
à l'époque tu as bon tu es dommage
j'avais été sélectionné il m'avait
refusé voilà
donc j'ai envie de pleurer
bon courage pour ce soir
nous prépare-toi au deuxième coup tu
auras déjà l'avantage avec les noirs
tu peux tu peux rester là dessus même si
jamais tu perds qui est probable que ils
sont très très forts pourra dire comment
tu as eu l'avantage au deuxième cours
il y a plus de points à apprendre à 2400
à 2002 ça c'est clair après une
simultanée
[Musique]
trop cool
parce qu'en plus tu vois tout ça
en fait ça vous fait jouer contre des
joueurs hyper fort alors que normalement
vu votre niveau enfin votre niveau le
mien etc je parle pour tout le monde et
ben on n'a pas forcément l'occasion de
jouer sur ce genre là vous voyez donc là
encore pareil allez jouer contre Maxime
Lagarde contre garamian contre
féminin etc
en temps normal vous n'avez pas
l'occasion de les jouer ces gens-là donc
là c'est quand même c'est quand même
cool une simultanée en plus c'est
vraiment en condition pour par rapport à
l'événement enfin je trouve que c'est
vraiment génial donc franchement
franchement si vous êtes dans le coin
que vous aurez la possibilité d'y aller
allez-y quoi c'est trop cool
simultanément censé perdre donc vraiment
tu vas en me disant allez je vais
vraiment m'amuser quoi
en tant que FM bah si mais en fait moi
faire une simultanée contre ce genre là
ben
c'est bizarre les simultanés sont quand
même enfin je pense même pas que à mon
niveau je puisse en faire une contre un
de ces gens là en fait
tu vois
non mais pas de simultané du coup toi tu
les joues
plus facilement oui moi je les joue même
sur Internet même même dans les tournois
des trucs comme ça mais du coup pour moi
c'est pas si on va dire que ça tenait
parce que je
l'occasion en fait mais pour vous dans
notre chat qui qui
n'est pas encore maître fidèle et ben
vous avez beaucoup moins l'occasion de
les jouer donc du coup voilà mais moi
oui j'en joue plein donc et puis moi je
la connais très bien enfin Maxime
Lagarde je la connais très bien donc
bien sûr que j'aime bien je conclue
parce que c'est toujours un challenge
c'est cool de le prendre des joueurs
très fort mais après
voilà quoi après cet appareil
tu vois à l'époque c'est un peu un
sentiment un peu différent mais
dans l'idée là simultané c'est pendant
plus pour un plaisir aux amateurs aux
joueurs qui n'ont pas l'occasion de
jouer contre ces jours-là quoi
d'habitude
et puis c'est validé dans le chat
ceux qui ont c'est vraiment cool j'en ai
fait aussi d'ailleurs
moi j'ai joué Marie c'est bagues en
simultané
notamment
la plus grande chose que j'ai joué
nous on avait aussi accueilli Marie
Sebag lors d'un événement à Nice il y a
aussi une simultanée
mais j'ai eu droit
j'ai fait une simultanée contre mvl j'ai
pas vu le jour ah ouais mais MDL c'est
c'est monstrueux quoi monstrueux
pourquoi ne pas fusionner bon ça c'est
ça c'est un autre débat
U et c'est un débat qui
qui est
un petit peu un petit peu difficile pour
l'instant
il paye fatigué si tu veux savoir
une machine
qu'en fait non en fait il est tellement
plus fort que que nous tous que en fait
pour lui c'est même pas un exercice quoi
moi ça va faire nul l'impression qu'il
va tomber là peut-être cavaler ici mais
qu'elle va les prendre à l'écran c'est
pas la fourchette
là c'est le premier match retour c'est
ça ouais
comment vas-tu
qui a passé sa journée aujourd'hui à
faire de la peinture chez lui d'accord
un petit commentaire de croco je crois
que ça va pousser la deuxième fois que
c'est posé le montrer la meilleure
ouverture pour les blancs alors
[Musique]
ça n'existe pas
la meilleure ouverture parce qu'il y a
pas de meilleur ouverture il y a sinon
ce sera un petit peu un petit peu bête
tout le monde a joué donc il y a pas de
meilleures ouvertures pour les blancs il
faut juste respecter les principes
ouvertures pour que ça se passe bien
ou être grand maître et être capable de
pas les respecter mais de s'en sortir
très bien dans l'idée
je m'en veux pas
il y a pas de meilleures ouvertures
c'est très bien ce que
c'est mérité
donc là les noirs qui commencent
ça va être joué oh là là ça va être joué
en plus Maxime ce genre de tactique il
est rate pas qu'elle va les projets
et ça a été joué incroyable
ça c'est un thème que qu'on peut enfin
qu'on voit souvent c'est un exercice
regardez ca va les projets de échec qui
gagne un pion fait fourchette en plus si
roi bouge jusqu'à va les prendre
cavalier on apprend à la finale est
perdu parce que j'ai un pion de plus et
en fait ici sur cavaler pro j'ai H3
et maintenant c'est cavalier bouge j'ai
H2 et qui ne peut pas rattraper le pion
sera H1 dame
et sur wav2 du coup et ben j'ai le
supercouage de Kim permet de faire dame
donc ça c'est un thème très très
classique en fait
le cavalier en fait le cavalier qui ne
peut pas rattraper le pion quand je suis
dans le coin ici en G2 avec H3
[Musique]
d'accord
je suis sûr que tu as tu as dû voir ça
dans le dans le dans le bouquin
de de Samir Robin et Kevin Bordy
d'ailleurs je pensais que j'avais mis
j'avais mis je pense la bonne
j'ai envie de te répondre non pas du
tout mais
n'hésitez pas pour autant à aller
chercher ce bouquin
qui était soigneusement soigneusement
rédigé par deux grandes personnes ouais
d'ailleurs c'est pas j'ai pas la bonne
c'était quoi c'était pas bouquin
FR ou
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et demander au
bureau
est-ce que
bravo
et voilà
ok est-ce que contraints
après c'est quand même
en fait si mvl il est fatigué il peut
faire des bêtises
[Musique]
mais en fait
c'est vrai qu'un joueur a mis des lots
normal va pas réussir à pousser un verre
à la faute au point de perdre une dame
normalement j'ai envie de dire
mais mais après oui ça peut arriver de
gaffer vous savez
qui va commencer en 3 minutes du coup
ça déroute comment vas-tu
donc je suppose que non à l'écran
de faire un échiquier sur sa tête vous
voyez il y a des cases blanches les
cases bleues
avec
comme ça
on a un échiquier à côté plus encore les
chéquier enfin la caméra
vous avez de quoi voir franchement
alors du coup donc pour l'instant par
rapport du coup au classement donc
Sophie qui est à 0 pour l'instant 0 sur
et
Maxime qui a trois et demi sur quatre
par contre Maxine qui est quand même
bien placé maintenant pour continuer
tu vois sans continuer on va dire son
salut pour la première place tandis que
guerian a deux points et demi mais sur 3
donc il a une ronde de retard et il va
affronter une nouvelle fois maintenant
Elliot enfin Diamantis pour pour
continuer la lutte pour la première
place avec Maxime Lagarde
voilà c'est c'est quasiment sûr Maxime
va jouer le pour la première place
devant la deuxième phase et Sophie pour
la pour la troisième
je pense que vu jusqu'à actuel ça va
forcément le cas donc après faut voir
entre
Eliott et 10 g aussi comment c'est
évolue bah si l'autre batigraine
il peut se rapprocher un peu et créer
l'exploit donc
il va falloir qu'il fasse quelque chose
pour cette partie là
voici maintenant
et du coup j'ai pas encore la partie ça
devrait commencer dans une minute on
échiquier n'a pas l'air de marcher je
vais
pas annoncé ta présence non je l'ai su
il y a pas longtemps en fait si tu veux
et j'étais assez au complet
non avant-hier mais j'étais très occupé
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que
j'ai pas eu le temps de le faire
bon car avec avec cavalier 7 du coup
c'est une ligne la 44 qui est qui est
qui est intéressant pour les blancs
j'aime bien les blancs de pollution très
solide quand même aussi pour les noirs
donc là il va défendre j'imagine le
petit pion en D4 parce que je me lance
je vous prends d'un prends celui d'un
point d'écart donc il y a eu ces trois
de jouer voilà
donc ces positions sont généralement un
peu mieux pour les blancs j'ai plus
d'espace
plus d'espace et fou et deux ok pour jeu
cavalier 5 j'imagine il veut se découler
c'est un petit roc et sûrement je
cavalier 5 au coup d'après donc c'est
pas une mauvaise ouverture j'ai envie de
dire pour Portugal qui a l'impression
qu'il tu veux quand même très solide ici
avec les Noirs il sait qu'il a un point
et demi d'avance sur son concurrent
pour la deuxième place avec du coup
deux points évidemment sur sur
papayamantis donc je pense que je vais
solide c'est pas un mauvais résultat
on a vu ça a été dit il est très fort en
finale donc
doucement il attend un petit peu il va
petit à petit dans la partie et puis là
au final
il rase donc
il peut continuer comme ça c'est ça donc
dame 2 donc qu'est-ce qu'on voit ce
qu'on joue c'est 5
est-ce que je joue plus d'âme baisser ou
d'âme C7 en tout cas il faut que je que
je fasse quelque chose car il y a cinq
ça a pas trop de sens j'ai envie de dire
pour l'instant
du C4 qui arriverait
de casser tout ça
mais du coup c'est bien parce que du
coup il va essayer de les changer les
pièces
et comme le dit apprendre les échec va
arriver c'est l'idée un petit peu pour
ouvrir les colonnes donc on sait pas si
cavalier prend puis c'est 5 ou 6 mais
c'est 5 c'est un coup qui va tout le
temps arriver en fait
ok on va bouger le fou
et
une faiblesse G3
sur la colonne E ça peut être pas mal
pour l'air pour les blancs avec un
problème sur le pion aussi ça
j'ai pas trop aimé ce qu'il a fait
Tigrane
et du coup on a forcé F6 ce qui fait que
du coup en fonction de ce qui devient
très faible donc maintenant on va
doubler sur la colonne E pour taper sur
la faiblesse ici manger ici entre temps
puis après faire le petit plan après
c'est pas encore terminé c'est bien
c'est encore très solide pour les Noirs
mais au moins maintenant et ben on a
envoyé on a un objectif c'est ce petit
pion ici
et c'est pas simple pour les Noirs
plus simples à jouer et ce qu'on disait
si on arrive à jouer des coups sans
pratique et qui sont sont bons
là c'est ce qui fait la différence ne
font pas gagner avec une petite avance
au temps après ça peut jouer
bah ça peut en tout cas être très utile
pour la finale c'est ça donc prise il a
mangé du piano
F4 logique pour empêcher le 5 et fixer
du coup la le problème en E6
sur un planning des matchs oui on a un
planning des matchs
on a je crois qu'on a reçu on l'a reçu
en PDF
[Musique]
donc à 4 ah j'aime bien A4 surprise
Tourcoing ici ouvrir des colonnes
mais attention qu'est-ce que jamais le
pion est plus en prise la Tour Noire
pour aussi partir s'activer ailleurs
est-ce que c'est un coup ici tout
profiter que la tour soit pas il a mangé
d'abord
OK
comme tu avais le pion on ne sait que tu
es pas protégé si tu faisais ça passe
[Musique]
du coup si tu F5
je ferai tout échanger pour
pour la fin arranger le pion intéressant
oui
on peut défendre comme ça et voilà la
différence c'est que l'option est pas en
prison on n'a pas mangé depuis à la fin
quoi
mais il y a une pression là il faut
jeton des 6
et voir ce que je peux jouer ce que je
peux jouer peut-être un ramer le roi ici
et pousser avec B3 C4 ça m'attrape
peut-être d'être un plan assez sympa ça
on met le roi en E3 pour venir défendre
le pion des quatre
là c'est 5 par exemple pas forcément bon
après prise et ma tour après
ce petit pion isolés mettre le roi ici
OK
ok je suis moins fan
parce que en fait si il pousse là prise
prise ce sera toujours faible
j'ai bien peur que
Elliott soit trompé dans la manière de
faire là ça avait l'air bien ce que j'ai
proposé non voilà et B3 C4 tu pousses et
ta majorité
ça majorité un peu bloqué tu vois tu as
un pion ici dans cette 3 qui est un peu
arriéré
si tu bouges ben tu auras deux pions
isolés qui vont être faibles et le pion
B il peut pas avancer parce que enfin
même échanger ça c'est pas forcément
l'idéal pour pour les blancs ça fait nul
ok annule très solide de la part de de
Tigrane
je me demande s'il pouvait pas essayer
de d'être plus précis avec les Blancs
F4 alors peut-être que je dis des
bêtises mais ça m'avait l'air pas mal de
faire un truc comme ça il essaie de
faire ça et ça
admettons toujours un truc comme ça je
fais ça
et là je vais faire ça en fait
la tour bouge pas
comment
elle peut bouger
là donc c'est pas si simple
parce que moi ce que l'autre c'est vers
C4 mais là il y a prise sur échec ça ne
va pas
je fais ça tu fais quoi
là
je mange ici on va prendre et je prends
sur chaque tu vois
et surtout redessine à nouveau
est-ce que tu peux prendre des
ouais mais c'est pareil en fait
et là maintenant je vais te débrouiller
pour je sais que
vous pourrez changer en fait il faudrait
que j'arrive à gagner ce pion mais
je sais pas comment faire à tout moment
j'ai l'impression que tu as peut-être
moyen de faire un truc même au pire ça
ça et revenir enfin tu sais en pratique
tu as envie d'essayer de de pousser tes
pions je n'ai pas compte que plus dur
pour les noirs de tf5 peut-être que je
dis n'importe quoi mais peut-être que
c'est trop long je sais pas je sais pas
si c'est 4 maintenant mais
je sais pas
en fait en plus par rapport à son
tournoi ou entre la première place la
deuxième place il y a pas vraiment de
d'enjeux parce qu'en fait ils vont se
rejouer après en départage
en fait il faut que tu arrives dans les
deux premiers pour pour jouer le match
enfin pour être premier quoi et du coup
vu qu'il a un point et demi d'avance sur
le deuxième je pense que la nulle avec
les Noirs
c'est c'est complètement
[Musique]
logique au final
la deuxième partie où c'est ça
dans le tournoi pour après l'utiliser en
finale contre Ben l'autre qui sera
premier donc par exemple Maxime Lagarde
peut-être qu'il aurait essayé de la
vraie canard quoi c'est de la pousser un
peu plus alors que là du coup il veut
juste se qualifier donc il a raison il
joue sa petite nul tranquille solide et
voilà quoi donc au final c'est bien joué
mais
trop le principe de ce tournoi c'est
trop fait Napoléon donc alors les
précédentes d'édition il jouait
l'ouverture Napoléon qui est une
ouverture un peu spéciale là non mais
c'est juste quatre joueurs quatre
profils bien différents qui se joue en
fait juste en toute ronde et en deuxième
partie premier deuxième contre 3e 4e en
gros je mets ça pour la première place
pour la troisième place
et est-ce qu'il y a autre chose un peu
particulier mais
se joue en blitz 3 + 2 en aller-retour
une fois blanc une fois noir et à
l'issue de ces du coup six parties donc
nous on va tous les voir une par une on
va mettre on a 12 parties qu'on va
regarder en blitz et
une fois qu'on aura vu ça et ben on va
avoir comme tu l'as très bien expliqué
les deux premiers qui vont se jouer en
deux parties en cas d'égalité il y aura
en armage ça veut dire une troisième
partie pour vraiment départager les
joueurs donc 5 minutes pour les blancs
et 4 minutes pour les noirs avec
obligation de gagner pour les blancs et
en cas de nul c'est noir qui vient de la
partie
et pareil pour la troisième place donc
il y aura aussi deux parties en cas de
guerre magadon etc et après ça
d'ailleurs
si il n'y a pas d'Armageddon enfin tout
et ben on va assister à une partie
par équipe
donc je sais pas trop comment ça se
passait si c'est un coup chacun ou un
truc comme ça mais une partie par équipe
avec avec
voilà donc c'est en 8 + 5 je crois et
par contre c'est bien compris si
arnageddon si Armageddon il y aura pas
ça je crois que si j'ai bien compris
donc on verra toute façon un petit peu
comment ça va se passer
et voilà donc là encore 4 minutes avant
le début de la ronde 9 avec Maxime
Lagarde avec les Blancs qu'on regarde
Amiens donc là
pour vous dire que la moelle les choses
pour l'instant Maxime Lagarde à 3,5 sur
garamian A3 sur 4
et ensuite derrière on a
Elliot papa diamant qui c'est avec un
point et demi et Sophie avec zéro donc
pour l'instant
Maxime je pense que les deux joueurs à
Maxime Lagarde et Tiguan Garibal tous
les deux quand même les deux favoris
depuis le début qui ont quasiment tout
gagné et je pense qu'ils vont pas
forcément prendre beaucoup de risques
dans cette partie
ils ont quand même leur tournoi leurs
calife à prendre
donc je sais pas ce que tu en penses pas
tout mais je vois pas un combat
spectaculaire avant pour cette partie
j'étais en train de relire les
options finales
extraordinaire entre les deux
parties
souvent je te rassure
[Musique]
à pas grand chose
à prouver encore donc il a sa place du
coup
allez c'est parti
c'est parti du coup on a C4 donc c'est
encore une fois
un début un peu récit avec B3
donc Maxime
et ils vont un peu ce qui se passe
[Musique]
et qui graines qui jouent qui sont très
solides aussi avec les noirs
quand même pas mal mais tu vois que
c'est Tigrane hyper la partie on va
peut-être quand même Maxime pourrait
essayer de mettre un peu la pression
atikarante tu vois vu que Maxime il est
quand même quasiment sûr de qualité pour
la finale peut-être que si jamais Maxime
arrive à battre
tigre avec les Blancs et qu'après
Elliott bat Sophie
tu vois dans la partie les joueurs
seraient à 3h30 à 3 pardon pour 10 g et
2 et demi pour Eliot
ça pourrait mettre votre pression
intégrale donc peut-être que du coup
Maxime peut en profiter pour essayer de
lui tu vois il est pas encore qualifié
en fait on va dire
je sais pas
un petit peu
parce que c'était assez ça avait été
assez rapide
donc on va voir moi je pensais que
c'était justement pour ce
changer les choses à la deuxième partie
avec les Blancs essayer cette fois-ci de
à la première et gagner au retour on va
voir on va voir si c'est toujours son
objectif
et écoute moi j'aime bien ce que fait
Maxime
cela peut être forcément très correct ce
qui nous fait Maxime
mais
je trouve qu'en Blitz c'est assez
intéressant
pardon en fait ce qui c'est ce qui fait
que H4 mais il veut jouer cavalle
il veut bon il y a eu H6
bon là je pense que c'est vraiment
complètement exagéré de faire cavalier 5
encore une fois mais dans l'idée ce
qu'il aurait voulu faire c'est de faire
quel G5 mais là c'est maths ici et
surtout prends il y avait ah je prends
qui ouvrait la tour et en gros et
essayer de ramener l'attaque comme ça
avec la taxe sur rachète avec un fond en
Détroit le fou aussi qui peut un jour
s'ouvrir sur le 7 donc c'est un jeu
assez intéressant ce qui nous fait
Maxime du coup s'il y a eu H6
intéressant
qui empêche
quand on est trois ok bon on a compris
je pense l'intention de Maxime il veut
mater du coup je pense que maxi il a
qu'à entendre mon commentaire et il veut
complètement me faire mentir et il veut
montrer que ben non il a pour gagner
quoi il a pour gagner et moi j'aime
beaucoup ce que Maxime je trouve que
c'est pas normal mais tu sais bon c'est
original quoi c'est original c'est sympa
c'est créatif et ça va avec ce que dit
fabulous c'est un peu c'est un parfum un
peu spécial et c'est de montrer ou
montrer un show un show échiquier donc
là lui
dirait combien
donc là par rapport on nous demande si
les gens sont tous grands maîtres donc
on va que fabuleux a répondu mais je
trouve que les vraiment le choix des
joueurs et assez intéressant avec
tigraine garamian et Maxime Lagarde qui
sont deux aujourd'hui du top niveau deux
des meilleurs joueurs français qui ont
tout fait partie des équipes olympiques
françaises et on a aussi ce féminy et
qui elle est multi multiples championne
de France et 2400 euros depuis très très
longtemps donc c'est une des meilleures
joueuses françaises et
Elliott pour dire what is qui lui est un
peu on va dire la jeunesse le jeune
maître qui qui monte en puissance donc
donc c'est un tableau intéressant
tu as un petit peu comme on avait eu où
il y avait pas mal de jeunes
qui viennent se frotter un peu à au
joueur qui était plus expérimenté donc
j'aime bien sur le tournoi je trouve ça
cool
donc
assister à un grand Rock Tour géant et
G4
[Musique]
contre une minute 23 donc c'est vrai que
Maxime est un peu mal au temps
il a joué deux et là du coup peut-être
un C5 C4 pour arriver rapidement pour
essayer de calme avec quel roi blanc je
vous rappelle qu'on aura composé qui si
il est bon pour faire ton géant ça c'est
c'est clair
après il y a même G4 direct qui peut
être possible mais qui avait des projets
je suis pas sûr que ce soit possible il
y a un thème comme ça dans la 44 avec
petit rock où on laisse le pion G4
cadeau pour venir mettre les tours sur
la colonne g je sais pas si on va
pouvoir le faire ici
il y a eu P4 d'abord il est fou en E4
j'aime bien j'aime bien citer cette idée
là
par contre
des 3 prochaines chasser le fou à [__]
à effet je pense qu'il a pas eu envie tu
vois sur les trois peut-être qu'il y
avait le fou qui partait se cacher ici
qui tu as le défenseur le fou qui vient
défendre le roi intéressant comme
conception
là-bas on va échanger des pièces
intéressantes
qui a eu peur un peu de l'attaque de
Maxime qui a hyper solide qui est
intéressant c'est le 3
3 3 3 2 3
complètement éclairé par Maxime ça qui
avait lieu le 4 Maxime qui est un peu
désespéré à la caméra on l'a vu
tu vois encore une fois c'est une partie
pour lui pour l'instant qui qui est pas
si important que ça vu que
vu que la calife a priori elles devaient
quand même être là mais
en tout cas hyper intéressant j'appelle
malgré tout
mais voyez quel point après après après
la partie un petit truc un petit conseil
on peut à tous là
appelez-moi
ça va se terminer donc je vais pas
bouger des pièces pendant que la partie
joue encore
[Musique]
j'ai 6 voilà c'est terminé il y a tous
les tons qui tombent c'est pas mal j'ai
juste je vais aller manger
il y a trop trop de pions Maxime qui qui
joue encore mais je pense qu'il va pas
tarder à abandonner
bon c'était beau en tout cas
pas n'importe où parce qu'il peut y
avoir un petit échec et tu reprends là
qui devrait quand même perdre je pense
mais
Maxime qui est un peu débité il a pas vu
qu'il y avait le 4
mais franchement intéressant la partie
parce que vous voyez que Maxime qui est
enfin le gros bourrin qui qui envoie
tout contre Tigrane qui lui hyper solide
et il a pas trembler du tout en fait il
a juste bien je regarde il a regardé là
on voit souvent on dit affaiblissement à
l'aile donc avec H4 réaction au centre
donc là très bien réagi il a brûle
cavalier déjà il a joué à 6 pour jeux P5
et maintenant P4 et fou E4 j'ai beaucoup
aimé la conception de B5 B4 qui vient en
fait virer le cavalier pour que le Fou
vient ici en 4 sur Detroit il y a
peut-être fou G6 ou fou à H7 je sais pas
trop où pour en fait venir avec le foot
défendre un peu le roi je trouve ça
intéressant comme idée
et du coup maxima je fouille les droits
je pense que l'idée c'est qu'il voulait
pas que le fou parte là-bas et préférez
ici échanger des pièces cavéler 5 H6 AMG
c'est le premier coup qui m'est venu qui
m'est venu à l'esprit tout à l'heure
quand ils l'ont joué mais je pensais que
c'était un peu trop abusé j'ai même pas
calculer tellement on parle de ça en
fait H6 que j'ai 5 c'est un coup qui se
regarde quand même mais bon en vrai ça a
l'air un peu bizarre tu sais que j'ai 6
là il y a un problème sur un cadastreet
là vous voyez
prendre S5
c'est ultra chaud en pratique je défends
le maths
c'est hyper compliqué
mais en tout cas intéressant mais du
coup ce que je voulais vous dire en fait
ah oui non mais c'est clair c'est clair
dans cette position là tu as pas besoin
en plus de faire en ligne mais en fait
mon conseil parce que je pense que tout
le monde l'attend depuis un moment en
fait vous voyez que
ici on a vraiment un H4 tour H3 qui en
fait stratégiquement est complètement
dégueulasse vous voyez parce qu'en fait
c'est pas comme ça qu'on met les tours
en jeu etc mais en fait pourquoi il fait
ça bah il veut attaquer il a il a bien
vu qu'il avait des idées de maths avec
une attaques comme ça qui peut être très
très dangereux en fait si vous avez plus
de dames et que vous voyez en fait que
plus jamais d'attaque sur le roi ne
mettez pas la tour en H3 ou tu comme ça
moi ça m'arrive plein de fois quand
j'étais jeune je me souviens
m'entraîneur à l'époque il s'arrache les
cheveux les peu qu'il avait et ben
il me disait en fait parce que moi je
jouais avec les Blancs un système sur la
Sylviane avec entreposé et j'aimais bien
en fait balancer des pions h et G tout
le temps tout le temps du temps et un
jour et ben j'avais une finale
si vous voulez non je dors pourquoi peu
importe recomposer et j'avais plus de
dames et moi ce que je faisais et je
continue avec G4 HK tour G1 j'ai mis
deux tours en face du roi j'ai poussé
les pions mais en fait j'avais plus rien
j'avais plus de pièces et au final à la
fin de trop pousser les pions ou de mal
placer mes pièces comme là il l'attend
H3 et ben je lui par perdre parce que
tous mes pions étaient faibles à force
de les pousser et ma tour si je la monte
elle est mal placée aussi en fait il
faut savoir que
on peut se permettre de pousser des
pions ou de jouer des tours comme ça mal
placé ici seulement si vraiment on a des
chances d'attaquer et si pendant la
partie on voit que ça tourne mal comme
là c'est un mal tourné un petit peu vous
voyez que quand il est 6 prix etc là on
voit que ça trouve ça tourne mal là il
faut commencer vite à replacer nos
pièces par exemple là maintenant qu'il y
a plus de dames la tour en H3 la
première fois là donc là on devrait
peut-être faire je sais pas à toi
par exemple on va replacer ailleurs la
tour on sait qu'on a qu'on la place en
H3 que pour mater là il y a pas de maths
il y a plus rien donc je reviens ici et
je pars ailleurs et après des trois ben
vous voyez que tactique et en fait bah
ouais pourquoi tactique regardez la tour
d'1 elle est pas défendue du coup bah si
je mange là-bas je vais faire un tour en
fait et donc elle est pas défendue GF2
qui est en l'air j'ai ça en l'air il y a
tout qui s'effondre après cavalier 4
alors que s'il avait joué de Sage ton
machin
ben ok j'aurais peut-être pu avoir des
problèmes autrement j'en sais rien mais
là ici après qu'avec des deux bah je
peux faire tranquillement peut-être toi
à chaque fin qui n'est pas forcément
très agréable parce que le cavalier en 4
il est fort il est là je peux pas
pousser à cause de Cava et ses trois
enfin c'est comme désagréable mais au
moins mes pièces se défendent et
j'arrive à
un peu à consolider tout quoi donc
vraiment en fait donc je veux pas des
trucs bizarres
quand vous voyez qu'il y a pas l'attaque
bon là vous partez de Maxime moi j'étais
fan de ce qu'il a fait en vrai j'aime
beaucoup ce qu'il a fait et je trouve
que son H4 ton H3 était hyper créatif et
hyper intéressant donc là c'est pas ça
que je critique c'est juste après une
fois qu'il y a plus d'attaque essayer de
de
vous comment dire c'est de vous adapter
la situation du fait que ben
il y a plus attaque donc on replace les
pièces normalement
la stratégie au final c'est important
quoi
c'est un bon conseil
j'ai apprécié l'explication
[Musique]
bien à cavalier G5
bah moi j'ai mis l'ordi et en fait qui a
été 5 ça donne les noirs
ce qui montre que au niveau des des
[Musique]
contre-jour c'est il dit ici cavaler
surprise il joue F5
il prend
et là il dit que c'est chaud
fou des trois tous ces quatre dame G6
c'est un peu mieux pour les noirs
ces genres
[Musique]
ces genres 0,5
on va avoir du coup
Sophie avec les Blancs contre Eliott
donc je verrais bien une petite
dernière toi
je vais regarder une petite victoire de
Sophie Sophie qui a pas encore démarré
son compteur serait cool qu'elle
gagne une première partie
donc cavalier 2
7 E5
plein de choses à dire dans cette
position Fatou stratégie la case des 5
Dame des trois là il y a un coin
important je pense qui va être joué
alors pourquoi elle se cache si c'est un
coup si important que ça ou ça peut être
joué d'accord
en fait mais tu vas voir qu'elle va
jouer il va jouer à 6 avant même de
jouer cavalier F6 ça c'est clair donc là
il va y avoir peut-être un petit rock je
pense
et sur petit rock on risque d'avoir du
coup
H6 je pense peut-être pour C8 voir un
peu ce qui se passe
mais dans l'idée en fait pourquoi se
cacher c'est un coin important
ok en fait je dis n'importe quoi les
joueurs ne
les explications et les joueurs n'ont
rien à [__]
etc alors je voudrais un petit peu
l'explication
l'idée en fait c'est que
généralement dans ces positions après
cavalier F6
on a envie de rapidement faire faux gs5
et manger ici pourquoi on va donner
notre bon fou contre cavalier pour après
mettre un beau Caval en D5 et une fois
qu'il prend prend un autre Caval qui va
venir un jour en dessin contre son
mauvais fou mais c'est plein terme
échanges bonne pièce et souvent on joue
à 6 pour empêcher fou gs5 et après on
joue qui avait des F6
je peux pas passer trop de temps mais
après il y a plein d'autres idées
stratégiques dans cette position il n'y
a pas que ça mais c'est vrai que l'idée
de faire [__] j'ai 5 c'est une des
idées les plus importantes de
l'imposition mais comme elle avait Gb3
déjà je comprends que tu as pas envie de
jouer cinq derrière une fois que je mets
trois
B2 même si B3 ça t'aime d'apprendre la
case ces cases donc c'est pas forcément
que pour mettre le format de
bref donc avec 6 CF4 prise cavalier
prend et il faut B2 et là on va voir
sûrement un petit grand rock
qui a l'air pas mal
il y a une team pour ça bah ouais
tu préfères quand c'est vraiment
vraiment chaud ou contrôler un peu plus
la position
[Musique]
de préférence là dessus
pas dépendre peut-être que peut-être que
j'évolue aussi
parce que
après ça dépend des positions c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai que moi à l'époque
j'étais grand rock tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps et
maintenant j'ai un peu calmé et je fais
pas mal petit rock ça dépend des
positions bien évidemment
pourquoi on se prend la tête on voit que
plus
mettez le roi à l'abri qui disait
en fait le grand rock c'est c'est un
coup qui généralement est assez risqué
parce que c'est plus ouvert vous voyez
la loi il est pas encore défendu il faut
encore faire croire bien pour défendre
le roi et il y a quand même des colonnes
ouvertes aussi sur le roi donc c'est pas
évident mais petit rock c'est plus calme
mais après ça dépend vraiment des
positions ici l'avantage je crois qu'on
rock c'est que la tour aussi elle est
directement ouverte
et même petit Rogue vous voyez aussi
c'est pas facile
mais après ça dépend des postes mais
c'est vrai que souvent moi j'aime bien
mettre le rang en rock si je peux si
c'est solide donc
quand même est-ce que serait un coup
étonnamment ce que je regardais aussi
taper sur sur
je pense que de toute façon mais sur ça
il y a tout le cas et c'est 5 quand même
à voir
mais tu as l'impression que ce centre il
tient pas quoi enfin
il y a des pièces
oui à part ah oui je te laisse commenter
ça me fait plaisir
alors oui en effet Sophie a un casque et
les autres ont des
bouchons d'oreilles a priori c'est parce
que là c'est un trophée un peu spécial
ils sont dans un auditorium avec 300
personnes autour et des commentateurs
qui commentent les parties puisque c'est
sous forme de chaud comme on l'utilisait
tout à l'heure une chose donc ils
doivent
ils doivent se couvrir les oreilles pour
ne pas entendre les commentaires et le
bruit le bruit autour alors
effectivement sinon en temps normal
c'est pas autorisé l'électronique mais
les casques sont autorisés dans les
cases ou autres bouchon d'oreille sont
utilisés s'ils sont pas connectés
on peut en avoir du moins après ce que
nous disait tout c'est que c'est plutôt
dans des cas particulier qu'on a
qu'on utilise c'est peu de joueurs quand
même qui utilise
cela
pas de musique elle a pas de la personne
au téléphone enfin c'est voilà c'est
pas du tout
je me dis peut-être qu'elle est
peut-être qu'elle a dû hard rock dans
les oreilles peut-être
encore une fois on a on a toujours les
les coups qui arrivent par par morceau
alors je reviens
5 à la tour qui est enfermée à toi
malheureusement
et
Sophie qui va qui va faire cette partie
malheureusement
quand même on a un petit peu plus lent
et normalement ça va être encore des
soucis de temps côté aussi
il y a plus qu'à faire échec à pousser
le pion h
pour la et c'est terminé
ça devrait être terminé
est-ce que tu es déjà tombé autant toi
[Musique]
oui j'ai une histoire mais je la rentrée
pas
[Musique]
perdu autant
parce que là pour Shine et salut Shy'm
3 + 2 la cadence j'ai pas de souvenir
d'avoir perdu autant
j'ai dû sûrement plein de fois tomber
perdre autant mais j'ai pas vraiment
souvenir là
rapide dans
ça
je la francophonie j'avais joué même des
tournois qui était dans le 06 là en
Espagne
donc je peindre j'ai pas un gros et non
plus
de c'est rapide enfin rapide c'est quand
même et victoire de Eliott donc
[Musique]
victoire assez assez logique quand on
voit la position
et grosse déception de Sophie ah moi
j'ai pas aimé son dame F7 hein je vais
vous montrer un petit peu quand elle a
fait dans mes fesses on voit le coup en
jaune
bah en fait on a une position aussi on
joue comme l'attaque donc peut-être que
dans le 3 était intéressant pour venir
par là-bas
et
j'ai trouvé dommage quand même
ici parce que ça échange les pièces mais
au final ce qu'elle avait vu je pense
enfin parti c'est qu'après tu apprends
on reprend on attaque là et là et que
sur fouet suite pour tout défendre ben
c'est juste très facile
et que sur faux F6 elle avait compté sur
tout reprend des 6 le problème ici c'est
qu'elle a vu je pense qu'elle a dû
couper 5
qui en fait perd la Tour Eiffel
et après pour prendre des huit ans qu'on
débute la tour est perdue
là c'est juste perdu quelques mois en
plus tes pièces sont pas actives j'ai un
super caractérison
et pardon
c'est vraiment ça qui l'a mis dedans
mais au lieu de ça du coup c'est à la
place bah elle avait une pollution tout
à fait bonne on va revenir quand même au
coup de Fatou tout à l'heure est-ce que
ici dans marche 3 était possible
je regarde effectivement c'est bien le
dommage je crois il y avait autre chose
que c'était bien
on a parlé de ça
parce que
soit un problème quand tu rentres pas en
plus
et
c'est pas simple de vraiment venir
défendre ce pion parce que c'est sans
que la position elle tient à un fil quoi
tu vois ça sera trois avec quatre déjà
et il y a même plein de coups bizarres
et j'avais vu une idée en marrante elle
a joué ça et sur grand rock je l'avais
une idée enfin tout faire de bien
j'avais eu ça ça et ça un petit piège à
la stouffe
qui fait que sur D5 et ben j'avais une
petite prise en dessin alors je sais pas
si ça marche ou pas mais je voulais
juste en fait essayer de jouer sur le
petit clouage qu'on avait créé avec la
marche 3 pour empêcher faut prendre du
coup puis on prend ça
le problème c'est que peut-être que ça
marche pas peut-être il y a ça
et ça et découverte
donc peut-être que je me suis fait avoir
un bon projet
et qu'en fait ça marche pas du tout mais
ça avait l'air assez joli
blesses donc le fait d'échanger des bons
pions contre des faiblesses c'est
dommage
donc du coup ça vaut pas le coup je
voudrais très bien reprendre mon coup
mon tour Eiffel très bien etc
ok donc là du coup on vient de faire la
ronde de 10 il nous reste plus que deux
parties avant de passer au
match
des partages pour les premières places
deuxième place et ensuite pour la
troisième place
et on a
Elliot qui a 2 et demi
et Sophie qui a 0 pour l'instant du coup
là on va voir Eliot blanc contre Maxime
Lagarde c'est une partie hyper
importante parce que si Elliott remporte
la partie et ben il
revient égalité avec Maxime Lagarde
donc du coup c'est pas encore du tout ce
qui se passe
finalement
il a pris un très gros risque Maxime
Lagarde avec la partie juste avant
envoyer maintenant
non non mais voilà du coup Sophie Millet
qui jouera la ronde 12 avec les Noirs
contre garamian on sait que Sophie elle
va jouer
pour la troisième place
et que karamyan et ben il est
automatiquement qualifié en fait de par
sa victoire contre Maxime pour
la finale parce que il a déjà quatre
points
et il a encore une partie à jouer donc
si jamais Maxime
gagne la partie contre Eliott il aura il
aura du coup quatre points et demi et
petit grain aura 4 avant de le sabarti
contre Sophie qui ne pourra plus le
rattraper en fait caramian il a son
ticket déjà pour la finale
et ensuite Maxime Lagarde il aura aussi
son ticket à condition de ne pas perdre
avec les Noirs contre
Elliott pas Diamantis
donc là je sais pas ce qui se passe en
cas d'égalité si jamais
Elliott gagne la partie est-ce que
il pique la place ou pas de Maxime
c'est pas qu'à son débardage en cas de
en cas de qualité
[Musique]
pour Shine en fait les précédentes
éditions Napoléon
mais
cette fois ci c'est seulement la
simultanée qui a ce soir à 19h qui se
joue avec l'ouverture Napoléon donc là
c'est libre il pense qu'il est c'est ça
c'est ça
donc 3 minutes avant
cette partie
donc là la partie je pense la plus
importante du tournoi parce que la
dernière partie au final entre garamian
et Sophie Millet elle va constat pour du
beurre parce que les deux sont déjà sûr
d'être dans leur groupe respectif
donc là c'est vraiment la dernière
partie qui est vraiment un intérêt par
rapport à la qualification
et on prend une belle surprise je pense
avec Eliot qui qui pourrait battre
Maxime avec les Blancs et essayer de lui
piquer la place
coiffer au poteau
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait dans la
première partie Maxime et Elliott
Maxime blanc
maxime a gagné
[Musique]
de me rappeler avec la mémoire
mais cette série au début maxime a gagné
c'était la fameuse partie ah oui il faut
mettre c'est parti où il avait ramené le
pion quasiment à promotion
du coup
du coup si maintenant
Elliott gagne il aura battu à
Maxime aussi donc un partout donc en
termes de retard direct il y a eu un
après les départages souvent c'est les
victoires
et ici
Elliott il a fait quand même deux nuls
il me semble ah non c'est pareil
n'importe quoi
je dis n'importe quoi
si Eliot gagne et Ben et ben c'est
égalité parfaite entre les deux joueurs
[Musique]
sur place sont aussi dans le chat qui
doivent avoir la réponse
en tout cas on va voir on va voir dans
la partie voir ce qui se passe mais pour
qu'il y ait tous ces débats il faudrait
déjà que
[Musique]
Elliott gagne sa partie avec les Blancs
contre Maxime donc on va passer un blitz
il peut tout se passer sur un blitz
donc on va voir
allez les joueurs qui vont se mettre en
place là
Elliott qui a les blancs contre Maxime
donc on va assister à E4 et toute la
machine qui a joué à la française
contre
contre Sophie
donc est-ce que maintenant ça encore
je pense que Maxime va garder les
ouvertures
allez
le 4 c'est 5
cavalier F3 OK
et là sans doute des quatre ou pas
des 4 il y a eu ces quatre OK
donc un schéma un petit peu un peu
bizarre c'est pas un truc très connu
c'est pas comme ça qu'on joue d'habitude
d'ailleurs ces positions
mais ok
elliottes idées dans la position
donc il a joué à 4 pour le fou au cas où
six
on pense que
qui existe alors je sais pas si c'est
ici
mais il y a une idée de cadre qui existe
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie que de te dire qu'il se
prive qui a fait des trois mais je sais
que des 4 c'est une idée
que j'ai déjà vu
un pion pour l'activité
ok
ouais mais je pense pas que c'était la
bonne position c'est pas la bonne
position
mais assez longtemps c'est pas
la pression c'est une position un petit
peu
qui ressemble un petit peu mais qui
n'était pas la bonne parce que je pense
le foot bizarre OK
donc là il donne la part de fou pour
manger des cadres donc du coup on s'en
fout prendre des quatre bah il clôture
un petit peu la diagonale du fou du Fou
G7
là il arrive
ok on va voir un peu ce qui se passe
la vérité moi j'aime bien les noirs
la donnée civique comme ça ça me c'est
un truc qui me que j'aime pas
la part de fou les gars c'est important
en vrai moi je suis un peu fixette mais
essayer de pas donner vos fous comme ça
gratuitement contre la cavaliers
il faut une raison pour donner le fou
quand on cavalier
vraiment
Tourer
c'est pas un pion gratuit ça
et le tour
[Musique]
qui a été ajoutée pour
exprès ok ça joue encore tu as le centre
quand même qui peut arriver tu as une
position un petit peu un peu bizarre tu
vois tu as le pépion H et G qui ont été
bougé chez les noirs
donc ça offre quand même un contre jeu
pour le blanc avec un des trous c'est
pas simple même si elle a peur de fou et
un peu plus
mais quand on va continuer
à Maxime pour passer pour jouer la
finale ah oui non mais oui par rapport à
pour la finale Maxime doit absolument
pas perdre
là c'est Eliott de forcer
et
si il gagne il y aura des je sais pas
comment ça se passait le département
qui passe en finale
ça c'est sûr et certain
c'est à peu près équilibré au niveau du
temps
c'est ça
prise tombé 6
c'est pas simple parce que même sur C5
tu vois je perdrai les 6
je peux pas vraiment défendre les pions
exactement
comme je disais il a un pion de plus
mais
il reste actif et il met la pression
autant
le 5 qui peut arriver un jour comment on
défense pion que tu auras assez vite
c'est pas un coup qu'on veut faire c'est
un coup très passif il a fait des 5
waouh sacrifie le pion
pour pour l'activité
sur pion prend ce qu'il veut c'est
sûrement tout reprend voilà et après ça
me sert peut-être
surprise là j'ai pas pu en prendre à
cause de la tu vois
on va attaquer E3 ouvrir le case noire
du coup et en même temps on s'enlève du
vis-à-vis ce qui veut dire que si je
fais ça qui défend je pourrais manger là
voilà donc
les blancs on va récupérer leur pion et
il y a ce petit pion qui avance quoi
[Musique]
c'est un peu de la peine
pour y avoir un genre de perpète sur
case noire
c'est un jeu de plus en plus les blancs
ici c'est parti
comme ça
je garde G4
les deux lampes sont mal au temps 35
secondes chacun
chez moi je vois qu'il y a un petit un
petit différent là je vois que sur la la
pendule il a 40 et quelques
avant que ce soit le délai qui avait non
c'est bien 35 secondes chacun
qui a attaqué la tour ici
et après F6 dans ces 5
attention Maxime qui est en danger là
danger foi
il y a pas d'échec là sur Saint-Germain
sur ça j'ai ça a priori
pour C7 a été joué tu apprends à 5 pour
mettre
fin
aux espoirs de Maxime dans cette partie
et chaque
j'ai échec
salaire archi gagnant pour pour Elliot
cette partie avec très peu de temps la
pendule
incroyable dame G6 a été joué
échec d'un mecisse ils ont pas de temps
la pendule il faut aller il faut aller
doucement là
un coup
F4 qui empêche le plus avancer
et en plus tu auras jamais de maths en
G3 parce que le jour il fait dame j'ai
trois j'ai cavalier F3 qui défend là et
là
il y a pas de maths il y a rien
je crois que ça abandon non
ça a l'air fini
en fait je sais pas comment ça se passe
je sais pas comment ça se passe alors en
cas de nul
la cavalier G1 c'est fini il y a plus
d'échec il y a plus rien
d'ailleurs il faut que les géants c'est
le meilleur coup c'est la partie
Maxime continue de jouer il a raison
c'est du Blitz après tout et puis il a
une nul d'une calife assuré
là maintenant il va falloir la nul
d'embêter
cette partie est terminée mais il se bat
quand même Maxime il essaie de trouver
des choses
à cet a été joué
et là qui arrive abondant de Maxime
donc
là j'ai besoin les gars
ah attends c'est bon on va m'écrire sur
on vient de m'écrire pas encore
on vient de m'écrire et du coup du coup
j'attends les les nouvelles
parce que là du coup on a pas anticipé
cette
éventualité jusque là où on n'a pas
parlé et
[Musique]
ouais
on va voir ce qui a annoncé sur place
c'est ça
et donc voilà donc là ils vont dire ce
qui se passe donc ça c'est clair les
deux joueurs
sont battus mutuellement une fois chacun
et on fait une nul aussi tous les deux
est-ce que ça va rejouer ou est-ce qu'il
y a un départage
en tout cas ce qui va se passer c'est
que c'est sûr que là il y a la partie
dans 5 minutes qui va avoir lieu entre
entre Sophie millet et tigre
et après on va voir ce qui se passe
entre les deux joueurs savoir qui
est qualifié ou est-ce que est-ce qu'il
y a du coup un départ
apparemment c'est il y a un département
c'est le seul
and bone d'argent
et du coup il faut attendre la fin de la
compète
ok nickel
donc là on va voir ce qui se passe
la dernière partie même si elle va rien
changer à la finale et petite finale
en plus les joueurs les joueurs ont fait
nul contre la même personne
ce sont battus mutuellement et en tous
les deux battus
Sophie donc l'égalité elle est parfaite
parce que je pense que si par exemple tu
as battu imaginons bah moi imaginons
j'ai fait nul contre contre Tigane
pendant que toi tu as fini contre Sophie
ben moi comme j'ai fait une gros le
premier ça peut m'avantager tu vois par
rapport à Sophie mais là les deux ont
fait la même personne ils se sont battus
mutuellement une fois chacun et ils ont
battu Sophie du coup en terme de
départage dans les dans les tournois de
ce genre en toute ronde aller-retour
comment tu t'es partages
au sort
[Musique]
moi j'aurais fait en fait il était
partage alors pile ou face
mais moi si je pouvais jouer
c'est une blague non en fait tu sais que
ça peut arriver des fois c'est clair
j'étais un peu crédule mais
c'est vrai
je pense que je serai assez fort
j'adore ça peut ça peut passer aussi
il y a quand même
il y a une part de psychologie aussi
alors quand pile ou face
ouais bon là c'est une partie qui compte
un peu pour le pour du beurre par
rapport au tournoi parce que garmen est
sur cette premier quoi qu'il arrive et à
Sophie sûr d'être quatrième quoi qu'il
arrive donc en fait bon c'est la ronde
12 donc il faut qu'il faut la jouer
[Musique]
mais du coup voilà là il y a c'est la
partie qui compte un peu pour du beurre
pendant qu'à côté et ben
on aura du coup
on va voir ce qui se passe entre
Eliott et Maxime
il a fait une bonne partie et surtout en
plus que qu'il a donné le pion en C3 en
un coup
et tiens celui qui jouait H5 kit pour
chaque c'est pas mauvais coup enfin
c'est pas un coup de Tilt l'idée
on prend puis on prend le cavalier il
bouge et après j'ai de la marche 4 qui
arrive et attaque de maths ici sur la
colonne h
du coup en fait voilà ça c'est un
sacrifice qui est thématique dans toute
sa position d'espagnol
un magasin apparemment
ok apparemment il y aura sûrement
sûrement un magasin entre les deux
joueurs
et donc à suivre un peu ce qui se passe
c'est pas sûr
mais on pense avoir un Armageddon
du coup ça va changer un petit peu ça va
chambouler un petit peu
mon planning qui était si bien fait
jusqu'à présent quoi
ah oui au-delà de bien respecter c'est
qui
après bon ils sont que quatre
joueurs tu peux avoir des problèmes
partout etc avec quatre joueurs bon
priori ça va quand même plus vite que
ok
il a mangé en G5 du coup attends attends
attends
OK
ce cavalier est perdu
comment est-ce qu'il va jouer là j'aime
pas du tout la prise de décision de de
tigramme
je me demande si il y a pas moyen de
pouvoir faire une petite attaque
genre
[Musique]
qui va arriver ouh là là j'ai trois ça
ça me fait peur
faut voir si j'ai le temps parce que
j'ai trois cavaliers eux tu vois c'est
pas le temps de faire le
problème qu'on voit tout sur H1 on
apprend avec échec et m'attend H2 parce
que j'ai un pion en G7 et sur ça ça j'ai
pas le temps de faire G6 parce que mon
pion qui était si important il est plus
là quoi
donc là du coup quitte à perdre ce pion
il faut échanger je pense mais échanger
ça va quand même donner la colonne F au
blanc
et que j'ai quand même des pions faibles
mais j'ai un pion de plus au final donc
bah écoute tu manges rock et puis c'est
la vie bonjour
prise
je sais pas si ça
ça c'est son problème
autant
après si c'est si c'est le moment
décisif
prendre du temps
c'est un peu le coup de la partie donc
ça se comprend donc
qui va arriver et après grand rock ben
j'ai comme ce pur en l'air il y a aussi
ça qui va arriver il y a qu'à m'attaque
attaque des Noirs assez sympa avec en
plus un pion de plus parce que le pion
je le prends quand je veux donc il y a
plus en plus attaque
et c'est clairement
bonne position pour
pour les noirs
juste le temps qui peut
et
elle a pris de l'avance au temps elle
est hyper bien
on sent qu'il a peur on sent qu'il est
roi des deux
et maintenant revenir avec la tour
ici et il faut aussi
et là pour prendre
là c'est jaune ou pas
d'un échec quand même
la tour qui est un peu enfermé après
après j'ai 3 ans j'ai peur qu'elle soit
pas fait enfermé ici la tour qui puisse
plus bouger maintenant
cette seconde chacun
du tout là il y a plus de temps du tout
il y a plus de temps maintenant qui peut
arriver un jour aussi
dans la 4
une fourchette là
je crois pas
elle se prise la main dans la tête elle
abandonne
c'est dur c'est dur
c'est dur pour pour Sophie qui qui avait
qui avait dominé lors de cette partie
encore elle aurait pu s'avec un pas mal
de parties qu'elle est hyper bien et
qu'elle se fait un peu arnaquer autant
enfin autant c'est pas autant mais en
fait elle est mal au temps et du coup
elle en date elle pèle un peu
mais là elle avait un gros avantage mais
si apparemment peut-être mieux à faire
kf6 son ordinateur il va encore mieux à
faire
ça ça m'a l'air pas mal
et
[Musique]
la pièce
de récupérer la pièce absolument
[Musique]
avec un plan de plus
donc une partie
Armageddon alors qu'est-ce qu'un
Armageddon Fatou
est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer
[Musique]
au niveau du temps ils n'ont pas le même
temps les deux joueurs donc je sais pas
combien c'est 5 contre 4 minutes
minutes
et celui qui a les noirs
[Musique]
ok merci
ouais en fait l'idée c'est que voilà on
joue avec 54 mais cette fois-ci il y a
pas de rajout de temps
54 KO
vraiment ça prend plus de grève la 5 + 4
en finish donc là il y a du flag il y a
du flag on peut flaguer
il faut être prêt ouais donc 54 le
joueur qui a des blancs à 5 minutes et 4
minutes mais en cas de nul c'est les
noirs qui passent donc les doigts
et en plus tu as une minute de moins
donc tout ça fait que en contrepartie et
Ben
et ben
c'est moi qui me qualifie donc voilà ça
c'était partage ça permet de faire une
seule partie et d'avoir un résultat sur
parce que
tous les départages like vraiment
égalité enfin c'était vraiment les
joueurs sont
neutralisés ensemble donc chacun une
nulle contre le premier et en plus ont
battu Sophie deux fois donc en fait dans
les deux cas
dans les deux cas c'était pas très juste
je trouve de choisir un joueur
c'est pas très juste en vrai donc du
coup du coup voilà on a on a du coup on
va assister à un départ
pour pour cette dernière partie
avant avant
les poules enfin les poules les les
phases finales pardon du coup
là vous allez vous allez assister à
au tirage au sort du coup pion noir dans
une main pion blanc dans l'autre
parce qu'on me dit dans mon tutoriel
vous assistez regardez qui le sort donc
je crois qu'il a pris des blancs
Elliott elle est blanche donc Eliott
elle est blanc 54 et doit absolument
gagner
donc Maxime comme tout à l'heure il a
les noirs et peut faire nul
alors il a gagné le tirage
est-ce que tu dis gagné en fait en vrai
quand tu gagnes parce que
il a choisi d'avoir les blancs il a
gagné parce qu'il a trouvé le pion blanc
moi contre Maxime Lagarde
j'aurais peut-être qu'il est noir
bah oui parce que bon bah blanc noir de
un j'ai la fille d'or c'est trop fort
mais en fait
[Musique]
quand tu es obligé de battre de battre
Maxime qui est blanc même si elle est
blanc c'est dur quoi
même une nul ça peut arriver quoi
il a comment dire il a il a trouvé le
pion blanc est-ce que ça lui donne les
pions blancs ou est-ce que après une
fois qu'il allait le lent il peut
choisir non je crois qu'il a pris les
blancs comme ça
il a gagné c'est que c'est lui qui a
je pense c'est le malade parler
t'apprendre les échecs mais je pense que
parce que moi j'aurais
pas dit gagner enfin
après il vient de le faire avec eux
ok ok ok ok d'accord autant pour moi
il a fait une fois il se dit deuxième
fois exactement
[Musique]
en fait à Maxime pour gagner quoi
je m'en fous complètement
[Musique]
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué ce choix
en tout cas il a pris les blancs ça
montre un petit peu aussi une force de
caractère un peu la confiance qui peut
avoir en lui
Elliott
tu es une partie avec une couleur tu
restes sur la dynamique ouais c'est
clair je comprends
c'est vrai que en plus tu viens de
gagner donc tu as envie de
c'est que c'est clair
est-ce que tu rejoins la même chose
je vous rappelle que la cadence il y a
pas de
rajout de temps c'est du chaos 100%.
alors est-ce que dans les parce que je
me souviens qu'il me semble des fois il
y a un rajout de temps dans les il peut
y avoir un rajout de temps dans les dans
les armagadons mais en fin de partie
genre vers le centième coup un truc
comme ça et là je sais pas si les
testicules qui en rajoutant à la fin de
partie ça évite les flags en fait ça
évite les flags
ouais mais c'est pas tout le temps
pareil c'est pas tout le temps tout le
temps le truc alors je sais pas je suis
pas sûr que ça existe moi j'avais vu je
crois que c'était pas trop sortir freiné
en finale championnat du championnat de
France avec un petit flag comme on aime
bien
un petit flag à la touffe c'était
c'était oui elle avait une finale
perdante il était il avait gagné autant
un truc comme ça
c'était un truc digne d'un petit stouf
tu aurais été faire de moi Fatou tu
l'avais gagné comme ça moi
[Musique]
je suis d'accord avec toi c'est
l'impression que tout est un peu emprise
là
d'un point F5
on voit que Maxime qui se rapproche un
petit peu autant vous voyez Maxime qui
joue très vite
il a rattrapé quasiment son retard
autant
et
maintenant c'est parti
de la finale et
tu as raison
[Musique]
ce petit pion tout à l'heure il a fait
des merveilles avec son action
il y a pas de tactique je regarde il y a
quand même la dame en qui peut taper un
jour ce petit tour ici des
tactiques
qu'elle va les prendre je les prends ça
l'idée je pense ah non je réponds il y
avait d'un point F2 pardon
donc là du coup il défend F2 et d'un F4
sûrement
un problème sur soi-dames
et les noirs sont très bien en fait non
j'ai envie de dire
attention
qui avance c'est 5 tours là pour 1
dans son mal c'est pas sûr
[Musique]
ici
du coup
et on peut lui
mais j'ai F3
c'est chaud en tout cas je préfère moi
je préfère
en pouce
F5
est-ce que je peux jouer
prise
tac tac
tu es chiant
attends oh là là j'aime pas quand ça
fait ça
[Musique]
j'aime pas quand ça fait ça je vais vite
et le cavalier qui va venir en V4 C6 B5
c'est presque pas de donner la pièce
c'est vrai mais ça gagne direct
donc là il peut pas jeter des quatre
donc là je vais sur mon cavalier ici
et là ça a l'air très dur
il est venu ici pour attaquer là et
maintenant peut-être en B4 maintenant il
va réussir
à arriver sur la case
genre ça et ça et ça et ça il passe par
là OK
tomber 5 B7
en tout cas c'est chaud Maxime c'est
malmené la 44 secondes je vous rappelle
que c'est ko hein c'est du chaos 44
secondes à 58
là il faut aller vite il y a pas de
rajout de temps
et tout là va arriver il y aura toujours
du cavalier
c'est très très chaud tu reprends un H6
Elliott il a gagné ça c'est clair qu'on
le sait
c'est évident mais est-ce qu'il va
réussir à avoir le temps de gagner la
partie
avec les 30 secondes ouais H4 peut-être
ce sera un coup simple et c'est d'aller
manger le petit pion en F4
chacun
un bordel
qui fait tout tomber
c'est horrible alors quand c'est comme
ça
il y a plus de temps ça va jouer au flag
c'est comme ça
il faut n'importe quoi
incroyable je sais pas combien de temps
ils avaient à la fin incroyable en tout
cas victoire de papa Diamantis
Elliott qui vient de sortir un maximum
avec 2-0
c'est incroyable
alors malheureusement on n'a pas on n'a
pas le temps
on n'a pas le temps à la fin de partie
parce que franchement bon oui c'est
comme qui sait même pas encore que qu'il
a gagné
c'est comme qui va nous mettre dans
quelques secondes d'un coup mais il y a
eu un match le roi noir a été maté ça
fait bien bugger aussi je pense
en gros je peux vous la faire comme ça
il y a eu un truc comme ça le roi il est
monté
jusque là la tour elle est partie
quelque part c'est pas où il y a eu dame
échec voilà je vous la refais un
franchement je suis pas mal hein la tour
elle était partie en fait en B4 un
garçon génie et franchement enfin tout
ce que je suis venu ou pas
ça ça ça
ça
c'est tout ce qu'on a vu à la caméra
ça je sais pas si vous êtes d'accord je
crois que j'ai réussi à refaire la
partie en direct de ce qu'on a vu sur le
tout petit écran en bas dans le chat et
la partie se termine comme ça je crois
bien Fatou
il y a un truc comme ça
je te fais confiance vas-y
je pense qu'il y a eu il y a eu cette
manœuvre voilà le pion qui arrive
jusque-là
c'est un risque de dingue et puis on l'a
vu il a mis plusieurs secondes
il a dû faire sa dame donc c'est
après ça dépend combien de temps si tu
as 3 secondes à la pendule la technique
écoutez bien le stuff qui est vraiment
un gros
quand vous avez trois secondes à la
pendule et ben il faut jouer du côté de
la pendule
en fait c'est la pendule à la droite
vous jouez les couilles genre tourage 4
tours H5 comme ça en fait tu es à côté
de la pendule donc pour appuyer c'est
très rapide c'était un peu de l'autre
côté tu fais tour A4 et tu fais tu fais
de l'autre côté en fait parce que quand
tu fais des grands gestes avec ton bras
tu perds plein de temps en fait à je
t'écoute tu vois et donc faire une dame
c'est horrible et oui mais après si tu
as trois secondes oui c'est chaud par
contre vraiment quand
tu as une position voilà là je sais pas
combien de temps il avait mais là par
contre si il a 10 secondes ah oui tu
prends une dame
tu vois
mais malheureusement on savait pas
combien il avait là on voit à la fin il
y a marqué 9 et 10 donc 9 et 10
peut-être que du coup il avait peut-être
15 20 secondes avant donc tu fais une
dame bien sûr quoi
tu vois mais on a été un petit peu gêné
par tout ça bon en tout cas c'est c'est
hyper intéressant de voir enfin
franchement je suis je suis très
agréablement surpris de voir Eliott qui
se qualifie du coup pour la pour la
première place avec garamian du coup
et franchement c'est mon truc tu vois
nous on avait dit depuis le début bah
oui bah c'est sûr ça va être Tigrane et
Maxime en finale
[Musique]
par un quasi quasi perfect donc il
arrive juste la petite nulle Maxime
Lagarde contre
un mais c'est vrai que
on s'attendait pas à ça sur les deux
dernières parties donc les deux
dernières parties défaites et mais il a
voulu faire le chaud il est là pour ça
et c'est annoncé
du coup ça a pas payé
c'est ça c'est ça franchement
franchement
[Musique]
très très beau spectacle en tout cas et
c'est vrai qu'on parle aussi de de
cadence chaos et non pas Fisher mais il
y a quand même du spectacle aussi tu
vois en cadence chaos au final quand on
voit
la réalisation tu vois tout ça pour
vraiment
gagner la partie franchement ça fait
assez un ressort
donc Sophie qui est qui est déjà en
place contre un Maxime qui doit être en
tilt donc c'est le moment bah oui en
plus parce que je le connais si un
joueur qui tilt
et
donc
voilà on va voir un peu Maxime qui a qui
va quand même essayer de gagner son
match et de terminer avec quand même
[Musique]
prends une petite pause en vrai là il
vient
ce qu'ils enchaînent à cause de cette
Armageddon toutes ces émotions
franchement
c'est vrai que
ok au Maxime qui joue du coup
un système de Londres tout ça c'est pour
Chester qui est du parti donc j'espère
que tu n'es pas là
c'est quoi ce tournoi alors attends j'ai
une question on n'a pas vu de jabbanois
[Musique]
toujours en février
à La Roche-sur-Yon je ne sais pas on
n'est pas Napoléon
du coup voilà c'est un tournoi qui se
joue avec quatre joueurs invités donc
deux grands maîtres top français
avec en score sur fumier qui est une des
meilleurs joueuses de France ever
et
Elliott papa Diamantis qui est en finale
qui lui est un jeune espoir Français qui
fait un excellent tournoi aussi et donc
voilà un plateau c'est sympa les joueurs
se jouent en fin je doute six parties en
aller-retour donc si partie en tout en
trois plus deux donc là on a assisté à
des parties en chaos parce que c'était
l'Armageddon c'était vraiment le
débattage entre les deux joueurs pour se
qualifier dans la finale donc là du coup
maintenant on assiste on a eu classement
un classement c'était premier
Tigrane caramian deuxième
Elliott papa Diamantis troisième machine
la garde et 4e
donc on commence par une partie de la
petite finale pour la troisième place
entre Max et mega avec les Blancs contre
ce féminin
avec les Noirs donc donc voilà voilà en
3 + 2 toujours
elle veut qu'un casque parce qu'en fait
dans un Audi auditorium c'est un tome un
peu spécial et il y a il y a un
commentateur
un qui commande tout en direct tout ça
donc c'est normal il y a un public il y
a tout ça et c'était pas c'était pas de
masque enfin de casque pardon tu serais
un peu à la rue c'est un peu compliqué
de jouer alors que
quelqu'un commente la partie en direct
donc c'est un travail un peu particulier
c'est du bled ça va vite je pense pas
que dans son casque elle est de la
musique
[Musique]
mettre musique ou pas je pense que
j'aurais toujours être musique
ça m'aide un peu à rester un peu
concentré
je pense que c'est pas forcément bien
parce que ton cerveau il est un peu
moins peut-être enfin tu vois je sais
pas
besoin de quelque chose qui
brille ta pensée arrière pour garder
ta pensée de l'instant présent plus plus
efficace
donc
en vrai pourquoi pas
franchement je sais pas moi je pense que
je
[Musique]
joue avec musique en tout cas je serais
parce que
ça m'aide à me concentrer quand j'ai pas
de musique je me sens pas bien
en fait
ce qui se passe quoi il faut une musique
ok
bon du coup partir à peu près normal
à s'équilibré j'ai envie de dire
quelqu'un qui va venir en quatre sur la
bonne case centrale ici et Maxime qui
peut être un peu tilter par la partie
enfin ils veulent perdre deux parties
d'affilée
et
franchement en tout cas chapeau pour
Eliott qui a battu une première fois et
qu'après tirage au sort il a repris les
blancs il a regagné quoi
franchement c'est impressionnant
c'est une belle démonstration un peu de
caractère comme tu l'as dit tout à
l'heure
mais c'est vrai que vu le début de
Maxime Lagarde on
s'y attendait pas on s'attendait pas
mais voilà c'est pour ça que c'est une
surprise donc très très bien joué très
très bien joué de papa
à la finale
après jusque là si gagne il a pas été en
danger hein franchement il fait son il
fait son parcours hyper professionnel
donc on va voir un peu ce qui peut nous
faire contre contre Tiguan en plus je
vous rappelle encore que c'est du public
donc tout est possible
carrément yes donc là
dans les finales aux deux parties qu'il
a fait
pas grand chose
il peut se venger
bien sûr que favori mais après
eliotta il est pas du tout un plouc et
il est là il est il est
il est présent quoi
donc non intéressant avec deux tours qui
sont partis direct un coup j'ai
l'impression
on a vu
le site qui a été actualisé il avait
deux tours qui sont arrivés d'un coup
ici
comme s'il avait pris une carte un
bateau échiquier pour mettre les deux
tours en même temps
et ouais
je suis très très nul je connais pas les
cartes à chaque fois c'est pareil le
jaune une fois tous les 10 ans je
connais pas des cartes
du coup moi je j'ai du mal à être
stratégie qui a anticipé parce que je
connais pas les cartes
donc en fait
c'est comme si quasiment c'est comme si
je veux quasiment aux échecs
contre quelqu'un qui les cartes donc
c'est dur magique
[Musique]
à toi donc là du coup bon final avec
léger pression des blancs quand même
sur les pions mais attention comme
autant les deux joueurs ont plus de
temps on voit encore Sophie qui a trois
secondes à la pendule
à moins que ce soit un problème de la
transmission il sort à peu près à 5
contre 10
en termes de temps ça c'est chaud bah je
la vois en fait sur le stream tu sais
à côté de ça alors ok
sur ta tête elle est partie
le
soleil qui a tourné
et non mais je pense ça va être nul en
fait les B3 et qui avait les B7
bon ça fait nul ça ferait prochaine
partie Sophie blanc
soit une partie là
[Musique]
donc là il y a quand même des
répétitions
Maxime qui répète plus allez ça fait nul
je pense ça répète OK
nul de Maxime bon Maxime qui prend une
nul quand même je dis pas que c'est un
super état pour lui parce qu'il a fait
les vents quand même mais après trois
défaites d'affilée c'est toujours bien
de jeunes parties de ne pas perdre
donc donc du coup là il a
il a
[Musique]
cassé la série de défaite et maintenant
la prochaine partie il aura les Noirs
contre Sophie Sophie qui elle a réussi à
faire nul c'est la première partie donc
c'est c'est intéressant aussi tu vois de
voir que Sophie qui a commencé avec 0
sur 6 qui maintenant en fait et ben dans
les phases de poules et ben un rond elle
se réveille et puis et puis elle fait
une nulle la première partie donc si
maintenant elle bat
Maxime avec les Blancs bah écoute Maxime
il sera fait coiffer poto
donc à voir
j'ai hâte
alors du coup là on va commencer après
cette petite interview on va commencer
avec la la première partie de la de la
finale la finale qui va qui va affronter
tigremian et
Elliott papa Diamantis
donc Eliott qui vient de mettre 2-0 à
Maxime dans
la dernière partie phase de poules puis
l'Armageddon était très impression dans
les deux parties donc Elliott qui est
plein de surprises avoir un petit peu ce
qui peut nous faire contre le très très
solide Tigrane
même quand Maxime il a fait au lit il a
répondu très très sereinement
franchement moi je trouve qu'il est
hyper impressionnant
je pense que tu en penses
aussi que
quand on le voit à l'image très très
solide préposé
très bien
mais bon à l'abri d'une nouvelle
surprise
[Musique]
je vois vraiment le genre professionnel
quoi qui est là qui est solide et qui
qui est vraiment stable en terme
échiquellement parlant il est très
stable
donc Maxime par exemple il est un peu
plus
comment dire il est capable de de
qui a pas besoin en l'air un peu plus
quoi son style en fait de jeu qui fait
que il joue pour le gain tout le temps
alors que garavian il est plus dans la
solidité je pense donc ça fait quand
même deux jours de style différent c'est
intéressant
non mais c'est vrai il est il est
vraiment tu vois il y a rien qui dépasse
quoi c'est quoi je trouve c'est beau
sur le programme ils ont de l'avance
parce que du coup en fait on n'a pas eu
de pause je crois enfin tout on aurait
dû avoir une pause mais du coup la pause
on va dépenser à avoir le le l'armage
est donc
[Musique]
du coup
on va jouer là
encore une fois pour pas me répéter mais
les fous si un prix je sais pas mon fou
gratuit comme ça ah mais c'est vrai en
plus les fous c'est important la cave à
l'écran il y aura match du Ramadan
quand même donc du coup là il va falloir
investir le foot
mais on investit le fou mais on a quand
même manger le le fou B5 OK
et d'enfants
et je pense que Tigrane est clairement
sans préparation enfin bon c'est
connaissance là parce qu'il a 3 minutes
tu vois quand tu as quand tu as réussi à
gagner
10 secondes dans les dix premier coup
généralement tu es bien là donc la pion
de plus et une minute d'avancer la
pendule
c'est pas mal
on dame B8 donc là on va sûrement
assister à un échange de dames on a un
pion de plus en fait
on garde bien sûr enfin en échange les
pièces avec avec un champ de plus et
maintenant on se retrouve des pièces
je veux bien aussi l'idée de faire ça
c'était Matic dans ses positions un peu
de de Rosso limer un truc comme ça dans
un cavalence C4 qui ne peut pas être
chassé par des pions tu vas défendre B2
etc
ça y est ça part un petit peu en
cacahuète là il y a une grosse pression
quand même sur le sur la diagonale
qui va monter donc il faut peut-être
défendre
non non après bon bien sûr
mais il y a la fatigue parce que nous on
commente on est là mais en fait eux bah
ils jouent et c'est pas simple
[Musique]
B3 et tranquillement quoi tu as même
Tourer chaque c'est pas grave je
regarderai peut-être c'est une finale
donc c'est pas grave d'avoir le Père
plein de temps en fait après je vais
sortir mon mes pièces
c'est la partie sauf qu'elle C3 qui est
sûrement mieux que je proposais
[Musique]
était bien je pense
tu vas consolider et après à ressortir
avec tes pièces les deux étaient bien et
Tigrane qui a toujours une minute
d'avance à la pendule c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup
il y a eu des coups là il faut que je
[Musique]
encore une fois un professionnel
tu as droit devant le fou et oui en fait
c'est logique les plans
c'est tout logique hyper hyper propre en
fait ce qui nous fait dire je suis fan
ça y est
très pro
non mais c'est vrai c'est propre en fait
je trouve ça propre
il fait vraiment
enfin il joue bien quoi
tu sens que vraiment dans ce tournoi
j'ai l'impression que c'est promené tu
vois parce que là il y a pas eu enfin
toutes ces parties étaient vraiment
propres et claires il a pas vraiment été
en danger jamais et voilà
je pense qu'on va l'appeler le
professionnel
non voilà je trouve que c'est
je suis fan de ce qu'il fait
toujours plus comment il jouait
et je me demande s'il n'est pas gagné le
fil d'ailleurs
avec son roi qui avait fait le tour de
chic et trois fois ça m'avait épaté
là-dedans peut-être qu'il passait Grand
Maître je sais plus mais après bon
25/50 tu passes tu passes remettre quoi
un jour quand même
donc B4 c'est bien joué surprise puis on
prend la colonne A pour attaquer le pion
ici très très très peu de temps à la
pendule pour les Noirs en voie tu vois
une minute 25 contre 6 minutes là c'est
c'est beaucoup trop
c'est beaucoup trop et ouais tout droit
et tu vois petit
il va jamais ça fait plaisir
gratuitement il va donner 0 contre le
jeu
food des quatre moi je vois un truc
comme ça je vous décr4 Roissy 4
peut-être fout des quatre mettre une
tour ici tour ici tu vois simple
dans cette partie
elle est elle est pas elle n'est pas pas
gagnante je sais pas comment dire
il a joué
j'avais échec PAF et paf et la finale de
fou avec un avec un point de plus fous
de même couleur c'est gagnant tous les
jours
et là il y a eu du coup ça et là il y a
un petit
tactique j'habillement
à 5
là il va y avoir peut-être tombé 5 ou du
Foussais 3
du roi C3
il a raté le match
pour manger la tour bon allez
dire que c'est déçu parce que
c'est maintenant
je suis un peu déçu quand même je suis
un peu déçu quand même des sous déçu
pardon
ok non grosse partie encore une fois de
de
tigre qui franchement depuis le début du
camp il fait son tournoi il enchaîne
la machine quoi la machine
peut faire la différence
ok donc là on va avoir du coup
après cette petite interview on va avoir
du coup
Sophie blanc contre Maxime donc ils ont
fait nul dans la première la première
confrontation là donc on va voir un
petit peu le match retour ce que ça ce
que ça donne
donc j'ai pas encore la partie sur que
c'est comme ça devrait arriver je pense
qu'on peut
je vous offre des packs final
non mais c'est vrai en fait je vous
propose
un doute tu vois sur le fait que
qui joue très bien des finales c'est pas
ça mais en fait je trouve que c'est beau
ce qu'il fait il fait pas d'erreur en
fait et il masse
là par exemple si je devais noter la
partie regarde est-ce que je peux faire
comment on fait déjà c'est review voilà
89 quasiment
mais en plus non mais c'est bien ce
qu'il a fait
OK
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il a mis qu'est-ce
qu'il a mis dedans en fait
je connais pas du tout
je connais absolument rien
apparemment ok bon
au final
mais je connais pas du tout
et moi quand je suis la première fois
parce que c'est pas le moment mais
[Musique]
pour te dire
tu perds rien
personne qui a entendu j'espère que mes
parents regardent le live
qui
je pense balancer la ronde
et
du coup donc on a la deuxième partie du
match Sophie contre Maxime
donc la partie qui peut valoir la
troisième place en cas de en cas de
victoire d'un joueur et ben ce joueur
arrivera du coup troisième de ce tournoi
bien sûr s'il y a une nul il y aura
armag et donc derrière
donc
[Musique]
là Sophie elle est blanc on va voir
peut
remporter la partie sur le dos de Maxime
ce serait quand même
très
bien
déception au maximum
[Musique]
avec l'épouse de chorizo et je l'ai
proposé hier de faire un petit match on
parie des rondelles
allez c'est parti
je sais pas si vous répondez
sérieusement le coup
je pense que oui
je te laisse lui répondre
c'est un trophée un peu spécial donc là
les quatre joueurs qui se sont joués en
toute ronde aller-retour en 3 minutes
plus 2 secondes donc c'est un peu sous
forme de chaud et chez qui là ils sont
ils sont dans le cadre dans un
auditorium avec des gens qui commentent
à côté et du public
et donc il y a une partie à chaque fois
et là on en est aux petites finales déjà
on en est à la fin donc c'est la petite
finale qui joue entre Maxime Lagarde et
Sophie Millet
et
la finale
qui va se finir de jouer juste après
c'est entre Diamantis
[Musique]
et toujours en trois plus deux c'est ça
donc pour l'instant dans la première
dans la première petite finale et ben on
a eu un match nul donc là c'est la
deuxième partie s'il y a un résultat et
ben le
classement sera figé à ce niveau là donc
troisième place quatrième place et dans
la grande finale et ben du coup on a
caravane qui l'a remporté sa partie face
à moitié donc il a pris la tête donc
pour pas Diamanti ce qui est une fois de
plus d'eau au mur et qui devra importer
sa partie pour pour arriver au
Armageddon
alors attends je vois que
on peut aussi inviter les ceux qui
suivent le live sur YouTube à s'abonner
sur Youtube ou à venir nous rejoindre
sur twitch et potentiellement aussi nous
suivre sur twitch d'ailleurs on a une on
a des stats assez marrantes qui nous
disent que
71% des viewers alors de YouTube et ben
ne sont pas abonnés à la chaîne
un peu dommage quand même donc n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne Youtube
c'est gratuit
et c'était quoi c'était quoi slogan
ça ne coûte rien et ça nous soutient
voilà merci encore une fois c'est quand
même faire tu es un génie
non en vrai c'est c'est cool il y a
plein de contenu qui va arriver très
très bientôt sur d'ailleurs la chaîne
Youtube donc donc n'hésitez pas à
[Musique]
vous abonner pour être au courant un peu
de tout ce qui va se passer plus tard et
pour ceux qui sont pas sur
twitch ou même ceux qui sont sur twitch
n'hésitez pas aussi à à follow la chaîne
c'est encore une fois c'est gratuit
aussi et vous serez à chaque fois
notifié quand on sera en ligne et quand
on fera des événements de ce type là
donc voilà
c'est ça à prendre des échecs c'est ça
Sophie Gan Maxime fini dernier
[Musique]
qui empêche
5 B5
après il y a toujours le temps déjà
et
toutes ces parties beaucoup de parties
les biens
mais je rigole pas en fait faire de fou
c'est très très fort aux échecs quand la
position elle est ouverte tu vois il est
fou comment ils sont comment ils visent
de loin quoi c'est trop bien quoi
c'est un peu sous-estimé
mais franchement faites pas confiance
les gars gardez vos fous
ne donnez jamais vos fous il faut
toujours avoir une super raison de
donner son fou
comme manger un pion par exemple ça peut
être une bonne raison mais c'est pas
toujours une bonne raison mais des fois
ça peut en être une bonne
bon c'est un pion de plus hein pour
Sophie ah non pardon non j'ai mal compté
mais bon j'ai deux fous
j'ai tout faux
généralement quand je vois deux fois
dans une position j'ai tendance à
toujours aller dans le sens de celui
qu'elle est fou je crois que vous avez
compris
cavaliers en vrai
et j'avoue en plus François Jacques
franchement de France
exactement ça
[Musique]
en prise faire attention aussi à ça en
pratique comment envie de se regarder
quoi pour empêcher ça peut arriver
est-ce que P3 c'est un coup d'en prendre
à deux et tu prends c'est ça quand j'ai
jamais mes trois
je ressors
et maintenant grâce à B3 il y a plus de
problème là il y a ça
ah par contre je perds ma tour donc on
va éviter bon je vais proposer un coup
j'ai dit une bêtise super j'arrête
je me tais-toi
qui est vraiment enfermée aussi
et
ça fait très peur
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup les blancs
comme tu le sais il y en a partout
surtout reprend
D8
il y a eu fou 4
je vous rappelle dans cette très très
chaud ce qui se passe là
très très chaud j'arrive pas à
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
excusez-moi qui arrive
prise là il faut revenir à la dame je
pense qu'il faut venir un petit peu
consolider là
qui va venir par là qui va revenir un
petit peu en vrai cette position en
blitz je prends les noirs
même si j'aime bien les blancs ou
non
je pense qu'elle a dû faire des trois
et oublier
c'est vraiment parce qu'elle a pas
abandonné en fait
ils sont pas serré la main
elle a fait dans B3 en essayant de
changer les dames la complètement oublié
que la dame vous voyez elle est clouée
en fait ça c'est clairement c'est dû à
la fatigue dû à la cadence 3 + 2 c'est
vraiment ça va très très vite et quand
tu contre Maxime Lagarde qui te met la
pression à chaque coup bah franchement
c'est dur quoi
c'est dur et
du coup
[Musique]
Maxime il est pas fier
[Rires]
et Maxime qui arrive comme 3e
lors de ce trophée et Sophie qui est
quand même beaucoup de raté parce que
dans beaucoup beaucoup de parties la
faire beaucoup mieux mais le temps on
lui a vraiment
elle a très bien cet endroit mais t'es
pas récompensé des positions qu'elle
avait
et
bonne soirée à toi voilà merci merci
d'avoir été présent
[Musique]
s
en fait dans les positions ouvertes les
fous vise très très loin alors que
Cavalli mais beaucoup de temps en fait à
se déplacer quoi même si pour vite les
cavaliers des fois les fous
les fous sont bah c'est des fous quoi
mais c'est vrai que ça on le répète
souvent pourquoi les fous sont meilleurs
que le cavalier ça dépend des positions
et bien évidemment on a des positions
qui sont fermées et ben les fous peuvent
pas bouger derrière les pieds en fait
donc quand la potion est fermée souvent
les fous ben ils ont pas grand chose à
faire et les cavaliers là peuvent plus
main d'oeuvrer et plus trouver des
choses à faire par contre on a position
est plus ouverte qui a pas de pions et
tout est un petit peu
déblay au milieu et ben les fous sont
plus forts parce qu'ils ont de meilleurs
diagonale et les cavaliers ont beaucoup
plus de mal à se déplacer
donc clairement les fous sont meilleurs
que les cavaliers de manière générale
ça ça c'est clair
les deux valent quand même trois points
3 points mais après
par rapport à la position ben ça va
l'évaluation peut changer
ça on dit souvent que que les pièces la
même valeur mais très souvent en fait et
ben
par rapport à la pollution l'évaluation
change en fait
c'est clair
ok donc là déjà on a déjà terminé ce sa
petite finale et on va passer maintenant
à la dernière partie qui est du coup le
la grande finale donc là dans la partie
d'ailleurs peut-être pas d'ailleurs on
sait pas parce que on a Elliott qui a
les blancs et
qui va jouer contre Tigrane garamian qui
depuis le début vraiment montre un
niveau de jeu vraiment extraordinaire et
Elliott va devoir gagner la partie qui
est blanc pour rester en lice et pour
forcer les leurs magasins et en cas de
de
nom des fêtes de Tigrane et d'un
tigraine sera sacré champion de trophée
Napoléon
donc
ce qui se passe
un peu ce qui se passe
qui va commencer en quelques instants on
va voir les joueurs s'installer
et Elliott il a quand même fait la
surprise tout à l'heure contre contre
Maxime il était dos au mur il l'a battu
avec les Blancs pour forcer un départage
et le rebattre avec les Blancs
donc quand même franchement
mérité tout ça
il y a aucun problème pour moi enfin
aucun problème pour moi il est tout à
fait en mesure d'y arriver
donc voilà après si grande c'est
là il fait vraiment un super tournoi il
est hyper en forme hyper sérieux hyper
droit regarde le hop allez
et il refait la petite
la petite
caracane tout à l'heure
et du coup
ça on avait cette position il y a le
cavalier F3 moi j'aime bien fout les
trois ici une ligne que je que j'aime
beaucoup avec les Blancs
il a eu celle là avec cava
ok donc il me semble
possible je sais pas si
je me trompe peut-être je sais pas
mélanger peut-être
une fort probable que je me trompe
donc faut être un petit rox et 5 donc là
c'est vraiment une structure
même type français
la structure un peu Caro calme
scandinave quoi
tu vois qu'on a souvent même française
ouverte
donc les Blancs ont un avantage d'espace
en début de partie mais après le noir
vont GBC
tours c'est vide dame C7 au final ben
les Blancs ont pas grand chose ben les
Noirs vont réussir à réaliser
rapidement donc B6 c'est un charbon cou
je solide
et il joue vite en plus
moi de la pression au temps je crois que
la pression autant c'est important
voilà la pression autant c'est important
un petit contrôle
le temps à 30 secondes d'écart c'est
énorme
[Musique]
il échange pour jeu contre le pion isolé
intéressant
j'aime bien ce qui fait qu'aduler son
fou vous voyez donc c'est pas bien donné
le fou mais c'est pas gratuit parce que
du coup il a créé un pion isolé donc
intéressant ce qui fait 10 g
j'aime bien
voilà mais c'est pas gratuit du coup
c'est pas gratuit échange comme je
disais la part de fou c'est sacré ça
donne pas si c'est gratuit là c'est pas
gratuit il y a la structure il y a le
pion isolé et intéressant ce que nous
fait ici 10 g j'aime bien le valide bon
sang
mais yes torser vite voyez vraiment très
propre encore ce qu'on fait le noir
essayer de partir en force tout ou deux
OK
tout donc là il y a pas de
reprend ça marchera pas parce qu'il y a
un petit vis-à-vis avec la dame ici il
pourrait y avoir un petit coup franc
découverte et je mange le cavalier la
tour en C3 avec Madame
c'est vraiment exemplaire il joue contre
un pion isolé donc il échange la pièce
qui est logique en échange les pièces en
plus elle a peur de fou il veut manger
la part de fou donc ils sont des pièces
et les blancs doivent garder les pièces
parce que les Blancs ont ou un isolé
donc avec un pion isolé on doit jouer
actif pour attaquer
par contre les noirs avec un contre
impur isolé doivent échanger les pièces
pour affaiblir au maximum ce pion isolé
en D4
par exemple ici là
cavaler prendre 3 bah il y aurait froid
E3 qui m'ouvrir la colonne F pour mes
tours qui viendrait aussi appuyer le
pion des 4 donc peut-être que du coup
cavalier prend 3 serait pas une bonne
idée tu vois
donc là il y a eu
6 ok là on avait il faut 3 je pense
qu'on avait un bug
ok c'est un bug je pense dans
transmission donc il a mangé ici
mais sur le long terme il y aura tout ce
petit pion avec un
on garde cette cible on échange les
pièces et puis et puis on va essayer de
taper on va essayer de taper des quatre
et là vu le temps
[Musique]
on a plusieurs il y a eu ça finalement
faut savoir
ok il y a eu ce qu'on avait dit ok bah
je suis pas si fan de ce qu'il a ce
qu'il a fait avec son petit cavalier
prend le 3 parce que je préfère aussi
ouais
généralement souvent pas faire à la
maison parce que ben ça fait pas mal les
cases blanches et le pion et du coup
parce qu'il se passe c'est ce qui se
passe en fait c'est que après ça
structure si tu veux tu tues un petit
peu le fou bien avec ta structure et tu
tapisses sur les pions ici en fait et
genre l'option pourra pas voir ça à
cause des pions etc et du coup ben c'est
très dur pour les bandes de passer donc
là il y a eu du coup dans mes 7 dessins
qui m'a l'air d'être un bon coup pour
essayer de déstabiliser et ouvrir sauf
qu'avant
prise et vous décides donc là il y a des
menaces de maths
2 et j'ai un pion aussi qui avance mais
qui a pas l'air très dangereux pour
l'instant parce que
sur 15 mois je suis assez présent quand
même j'ai trois a été joué fait
l'empêcher le matin alors le match je le
montre
si on joue par un blush je passe mon
tour là j'ai foi H2 voilà et la fouche
G3 importante qui permet de faire matte
au prochain coup voilà et du coup là
j'ai trois pour empêcher le mat donc il
t’imprompt bien évidemment on va
échanger les dames parce que là une
position avec Full reposer
donc
la stratégie c'est une
parce qu'il a déjà gagné la partie
d'avant
donc si il fait nul il est champion
là on va voir le fou ici ou ici plutôt
H3 je pense parce que tu auras 5 je suis
pas sûr que ça nous aide
c'est pas le moment
et on active le roi
tant qu'elle est tour la nuit n'est pas
assuré
il y a le roi noir est actif ce pion il
va nulle part pour l'instant
faut faire attention on va prendre ici
c'est possible je pense que oui
et maintenant bah c'est une position où
mais il a mangé depuis un 4 en plus
ouais
c'est une position a priori ne perdra
pas et va d'ailleurs même je peux gagner
ça a l'air terminé
même ça j'ai G4 qui va vite sur après
j'ai échec et découverte
il a fait H5
et en fait au final ben écoutez
mes pions sont bien plus avancés en plus
la grignoter le petit pion à deux
je pense que sans la fin pour Eliott
parce que dans le meilleur meilleur des
cas et ben il fera nul Elliott ce qui
fera que ben il aura perdu ce mini match
contre Tigrane
qui s'empresse de tout liquider mais la
raison bah oui ben il joue pour gagner
quoi
il fait nul il prend puis on V3 et ça
fait nul direct même pas essayer de
jouer hein qui va qui va tomber
donc voilà
on est revenu au 19e coup j'ai pas la
suite ça a buggé je crois mais ok on a
vu un peu la caméra ce qui se passait en
tout cas belle prestation encore une
fois de petits graines qui qui a fait un
tournoi vraiment excellent quoi il a
jamais tendance dans une partie je crois
[Musique]
il a dû jouer
la deuxième contre la garde
il a jamais été mal quoi
plus
2 en finale il a huit parties
et sur le lieu parti n'a jamais été en
danger
et ça franchement bah tu vois c'est il
mérite franchement c'est le genre qui a
le mieux
et il mérite clairement
son titre
donc du coup je viens song non il y a
pas Julien
donc le
donc champion du tournoi du coup bah
c'est 6 garamyan
suivi de
Eliott papa Diamantis deuxième et en
troisième position du coup et ben on va
avoir
Maxime Lagarde suivi de
Sophie millet en quatrième place donc
j'ai une question juste attends je vais
écrire une seconde
[Musique]
du coup on a le droit normalement au
parti en duo
justement c'est ma question
parce que je pense que je peux y
répondre
non c'est pas vrai
totalement
[Musique]
c'est là que vient la partie en double
une partie envie de plus simple comme tu
disais
j'ai encore mon problème de
quand j'écris tout en temps et parfois
je l'avais changé une fois en plus
[Musique]
je le ferai après j'enlèverai moi à la
fin du stream parce que là si je change
quelque chose ça va enlever la tête de
Fatou malheureusement
c'est pas grave je pense de la voir
il y a une appartement ça va doublette
je vais essayer d'écrire tout petit sans
faire de bruit
c'est pour ça vous voyez
le parti donc c'est un mon cerveau d'y
apprendre des échecs
c'est dans 10 minutes non parce qu'on
aurait une pause
il y en a une seule
donc moi ça vaut dans 10 minutes
dans 10 minutes mais ce que il garde pas
leur avance puisque depuis le début il
faut tout en avant je ne sais pas
on n'a pas pris de pause encore
parfait allez ça marche alors je vous
laisse une petite page de pub et on
revient dans un instant
voilà voilà à tout de suite
non c'est bon somme de retour avec la
grande fat
oh là là alors du coup
j'ai pas suivi ce qui se passe là est-ce
que c'est installé est-ce qu'on est bon
je n'ai pas accès à la caméra encore je
suis comme vous en fait ce que vous
voyez je le vois
et du coup
on va voir très vite si ça reprend et si
du coup on pensait pas quelles sont les
équipes derrière
quelles sont les équipes je pense qu'ils
vont être un grand maître dans chaque
équipe
comme tirage au sort
alors on va voir en tout cas ce qui se
passe
ce qu'on a des
[Musique]
retransmis on a rien
pour l'instant
j'ai
j'ai pas la partie Sanchez comme qui est
ouverte et la caméra et la façon s'il y
a pas de caméra c'est qu'il y a en train
de le faire
donc dès qu'on aura la caméra sur le
planning
on avait dit
17h15 normalement c'était la préparation
à la base
sur la préparation mais c'est avant de
commencer la partie sur le planning
d'origine
un peu avant 17h20
donc bon toujours un peu en avance dans
quelques quelques minutes on va avoir du
coup
on va voir en quelques minutes
pour le tirage au sort
quelle équipe tu aimerais voir
dans ce sens-là
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien avoir peut-être les deux
bourrins ensemble
[Musique]
ensemble contre
qu'est-ce que tu en penses toi
[Musique]
quelqu'un de ton niveau
comprend mieux alors après là ils ont
tous des gros niveau mais
peut-être que la paire de GM contre la
paire de mi ça peut
ça peut faire des trucs plus sensés
[Musique]
comme ça
on avait joué en Top 12 et quelques
[Musique]
et on aura mis deux euros
en un cerveau parce qu'en fait eux ils
étaient des idées ils voulaient tout le
balancer dans la gueule chaque partie
est sacrifié tout
et
puis c'est engueuler
et nous bah écoute on se comprenait on
était nul tu vois donc Bouba c'était
facile quoi et on a les deux zéro contre
Prague et Prague donc c'était pas les
Pragues de maintenant c'était maintenant
ils ont 2700 mais quand on les a joué
ils avaient déjà 25 ans 26 quoi
[Musique]
il y a quelques années maintenant à
l'époque j'étais 1400
un peu
un peu des échecs c'est quand tu cours
c'est ça
moi je l'ai connu comme ça
que je l'ai connu c'était d'ailleurs je
me suis cassé cassé une jambe
et je suis arrivé à l'hôpital et mon
père qu'est-ce qu'il a fait oh il a le
droit
jusqu'à ces gens en genre d'échec
et du coup voilà oui non mais oui en
fait tu as l'air pendule pour ceux qui
connaissent pas en fait les conduit de
chasse et ben tu joues des choses
normalement avec une pendule et en fait
d'avoir tu places ton échiquier à
environ une dizaine de mètres de la
pendule et à chaque coup fallait courir
pour appuyer sur la pendule et revenir
sur ton cou et en gros du coup ça c'est
sportif et
voilà donc quand tu es mal au temps il
faut vraiment courir vite
et tu sais que je l'ai fait dans la
piscine aussi j'ai mis j'avais mis la
pendule de l'autre côté de la piscine et
à chaque coup c'est un aller-retour et
la pluie n'était pas très très grande tu
vois elle faisait quoi
elle faisait je sais plus peut-être
je sais plus mais genre 10 mètres sur 10
un truc comme ça quoi tu vois
c'est grand quand même
les piscines de ouf quoi
[Musique]
je me suis réveillé et j'avais des
courbatures de ouf sur les bras je
pouvais plus bouger je pouvais plus
acheter comme ça je pouvais plus monter
les bras je pouvais pas
[Rires]
horrible
maintenant horrible
sport
dans la piscine je te garantis que pas
de revanche
ça va reprendre maintenant il faut
savoir prendre
c'est parfait
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui sont qui sont doués
d'origine je pense tu vois des gens
c'est
faut pas expliquer quoi juste tu les
connais quoi tu vois c'est
pas de sens
on a compris souvent
on a compris
alors ça va reprendre j'ai toujours pas
la caméra
ça y est on a les on a un visuel
avec nos joueurs plus l'arbitre
et on a les attends on a les deux grands
maîtres ensemble
et
va voir un petit peu comment ça va joue
je sais pas comment ça va être
[Musique]
c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être un signe
ça pas encore été fait le tirage au sort
je cherche des artistes je veux savoir
je pense que Sophie est la marque elle a
avancé deux fois
d'avance sur
6 grammes donc elle n'est pas avec lui
qui sont quitte avec qui
croisent les bras
peut-être que du coup c'est sorti
non plus j'ai pas la 18
l'équipe 1 contre équipe de un qui est
super
je suis
je clique dessus par contre quand j'ai
cliqué dessus j'ai pas de partie je
crois qu'il m'écoute en fait pour ça que
je parle à haute voix
est-ce que je clique sur le lien du coup
apprendre les échecs
c'est ce que tu voulais c'est ce que je
voulais il m'a accomplie bravo
merci alors du coup moi j'ai la partie
qui même là la partie en fait sur le
OK
tu as vu il y a quand même des signes
qui trompent pas
est-ce que tu es là Nathan
sinon pour ceux qui ont des
ordinateurs assez grands pour pour
observer la partie
Facebook
pardon
regarde Facebook attends mais je suis en
train de
que tu m'as fait encore sur Facebook
[Musique]
on entend pas les
les cerveaux parlaient
un cerveau donc ils sont par deux le
cerveau donne le nom d'une pièce par
exemple fou d'âme sans donner le case ou
d'âme pion et la main doit jouer mais il
y a pas de communication entre les
binômes l'idée c'est d'essayer de se
connecter à son adversaire de comprendre
son plan et de
pour l'un comme pour l'autre pour la
main comme pour le cerveau
voilà en gros voilà bon je vous ai mis
la partie en direct on le voit en grand
et
sur le stream
non mais ça va t'inquiète ça va on va
suivre sur ça je pense pas de flèche
mais
je vais faire un truc
voilà on va rester là dessus on sera
très bien
alors
du coup
attends je veux juste faire un petit
truc j'espère que ça va pas tout changé
ça change ou pas ce que j'ai fait ouais
ça change j'ai fait n'importe quoi je
suis désolé je voulais la faire
je suis désolé je vous ai fait un truc
pas bien je vais vous le refaire
un truc de
changer de page un truc
du coup
t'inquiète pas je la range
je suis caché pour la ranger
[Musique]
on a rien vu
non non en fait
pourquoi attends excuse-moi j'ai encore
un bug pourquoi c'est parti dégage c'est
pas ma faute là
[Musique]
technique
merci François Jacques c'est bon
[Musique]
je suis désolé les gars ça marchait très
bien jusque là
d'un coup Fatou elle parie
je me dépêche
mais tu vois ça joue ça joue plutôt
tranquille je pense que le fait d'être à
deux aussi tu t'obliges à te raisonner
un petit peu
bah ils veulent pas faire n'importe quoi
[Musique]
et je pense qu'il doit
il doit aussi se dire allez on va y
aller à tranquille
bah c'est parfait
il se débrouille avec
alors c'est une stratégie aussi
ce qui se passe
le G5 qui fait rire
avec les avec les Noirs ils vont envoyer
ils sont ils sont là pour ça
[Musique]
mais
petit duo comme ça non sympa bon ça
manque bien que c'est vraiment pour le
show pour le spectacle et la bonne
ambiance quoi salut
il veut s'amuser quoi
[Musique]
donc dès que tu peux tu envoies G4 G5
il parle bien
alors du coup
qui était obligatoire en fait enfin ou
pas lui qui était possible aussi
j'ai plusieurs coups
que tu vas avancer
en plus c'est clair
c'est la même pièce que tu bouges donc
en fait quand on couche est dame ben en
fait tu peux le savoir
donc faut aussi jouer très logique
entre nous on va se le dire
[Musique]
gros avantage blanc qui avait des
clients F5 c'est un massacre mais qui
allez on se bat on garde les pièces
on garde les pièces et puis comment
[Musique]
G7 sera inévitable et quand tu apprends
le four en G7 c'est bien c'est au
préalable tu peux commencer à jouer des
quatre pour ouvrir un peu les cases
noires tu vois manger le foutage noir tu
vois tu vas jouer contre le fou adverse
des Noirs qui ne rend plus
donc quand tu manges les cases noires
après tu joues sur le casemar genre D4
une fois que tu joues des quatre
et ben tu pourras manger en G7 prendre
un V5 ouais mais c'est pas grave ça en
fait je pense qu'on s'enjaque parce que
après je mangeais 7 je mange en E5
et après les gaz noirs dessus moi je
suis assez content au final d'ouvrir la
position
moi j'avais bien des quatre en vrai
et ça c'est tigre quoi il laisse rien
quoi j'ai rien alors que moi je te
garantir que Maxime
il est renoncé pion c'est tranquille
cavalier tu as un professionnel quoi
c'est ça on manœuvre on essaie de faire
en sorte que vraiment toutes les pièces
toi
ultra utiles au moment où
ça va exploser
H5 est-ce qu'on peut jouer ici un petit
G3
j'ai 3 pour empêcher le j'ai trop
arrêter de jouer empêche le Caval de
venir en F4
après quand on fait attention pour pas
avoir ses pions qui sont en prison non
plus donc toujours ça même des fois tu
peux même mettre le roi en G2 pour pour
bien
s'améliorer mes rois G2 il y a quand
même cavalier F4 qui peut arriver des
fois enfin vraiment attention à ça que
j'ai quatre très bien joué
ouais positionnellement c'est un
massacre
on va voir on va avoir rouage de je
pense
même la roi j'ai deux
s'il prend cavalier je prends du pion h
j'ouvre la colonne h pour ma tour c'est
dur
en fait Sophie elle a une position qui
est assez facile à jouer
et du coup Tigrane
ben ouais c'était bien tous les deux
alors que du coup Maxime il a en train
d'essayer de foot le bordel avec du coup
Eliott qui doit entre guillemets subit
après c'est Elliott quand même là la
main c'est des binômes
ah oui ben oui je pense que c'était
mieux tu mets les jeunes ensemble qui
veulent tout envoyer contre les les on
va dire les voir plus
expérimenté tu vois plus sérieux on va
dire je pense que c'est arrivé c'est un
bon mot
donc voilà tranquille
tout refait les anciens parents les
anciens quand même
[Musique]
de
pourquoi pas c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que le pion en G5 en fait plus les Noirs
avancent les pions du roi tout ça plus
les faiblesses vont se voir
donc voilà cavaler des sets et
maintenant on va sûrement voir cavalier
F3 arriver le retour du Cavaillon F3 qui
vient taper la faiblesse en G5
ouais
il améliore toi à 100%
pour venir défendre ce pion en G5 et un
jour même peut-être chargé 4 voilà et
tout à l'heure
je pensais mais si un coup mais
une bêtise alors prendre en A4 c'est
quand même une possibilité
à la fin il y aurait d'un point fou
du coup c'est pas encore une proposition
H4 là j'aime bien ce petit coin H4
va voir si ça marche vraiment
parce que H4 sur 4
et sur pion prend
H4 il faut réfléchir un peu il faut
prendre H6 cardiaque je pense que c'est
fini en fait
c'est un c'est très dur soit foutrant il
y a fou prends et la dame peut aller que
en H8 tu vois un peu la difficulté des
trucs carrément
très bien
H4
terminé et même dans celle-là Tigrane
aura été ça abandon même dans celle-là
qui graine aurait été encore une fois
majestueux propre
incroyable
incroyable salut lotide et le type c'est
apprendre le déchet
ok donc du coup victoire victoire de de
tigre Amiens et Sophie Millet contre
contre Maxime Lagarde et
Elliott papa Diamanti ils sont pas la
voir rapidement si vous voulez le parti
avoir un peu un accéléré E4 5 avaler 3
cavaler c'est 6 ou B5 espanol cavalier 3
on avance un petit peu ces trois à six
donc là tout est à peu près normal donc
là H6 ok H3 B5 et rock qui est des deux
tours vides bon tout ça à peu près
standard j'ai envie de dire
BK
je ne sais pas
pour qu'il revienne là ici avec A4 les
Blancs ont quand même réussi les deux
temps dans l'ouverture c'est quand même
assez cool qui vient en B3 le fou qui
vient
G5 il envoie tout d'Ama 2 et là il y a
une petite tactique avec le coin F7
et dame B3 tours à 4 et là c'est
vraiment
la leçon d'échec j'ai trois que j'ai 4
tours
et puis là H4 c'est fin de la partie en
fait H4 si le pion prend en H4 ben je
mange en H6 et sur je regarde
je peux pas défendre le pion H5 le
cavalier noir en G6 qui défend enfin qui
qui bloque le fou de la défense pourrez
bouger mais il a pas de case en fait on
pourrait H4 mais sur achat il y a une
cavalier prend H4 bon c'est une
boucherie quoi c'est complètement
terminé donc voilà donc on fait un petit
topo rapidement du coup par rapport au
tournoi donc on a
tigraine gramian champion du Trophée
Napoléon devant
Elliot papa Diamantis deuxième place
troisième place on a Maxime Lagarde et
quatrième place du coup on va avoir
Sophie millet et là pour la partie
Massaro qui était une partie un petit
peu or tournoi qui n'a rien à voir et
ben la partie donc on avait
Sophie Millet et qui ont battu avec les
Blancs
le couple du coup Maxime Lagarde et
Elliot papa Diamantis donc voilà voilà
donc je crois pas tout que pour nous
c'est c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
pour eux du coup ce qui sont sur les
dans les alentours de La Roche-sur-Yon
il y a la simultanée grande simultanée
donnée par les quatre mêmes joueurs ce
soir
19h21
annoncé c'est ça ouais donc pour ceux
qui sont pas loin même ceux qui peuvent
pas participer vous êtes pas loin aller
voir franchement c'est cool il y a tout
Testard françaises qui sont ici donc
c'est ça reste à voir c'est un super
événement donc merci encore une fois à
cheeseccom Fr pour pour le stream merci
aussi à biswiller chess
et après les échec pour pour le tournoi
pour l'organisation et pour Ben tout ce
que pour tout ça quoi c'est vraiment
sur place parce que nous on sait pas
forcément on est loin on est loin
et puis voilà puis merci encore à Fatou
d'avoir accompagné encore aujourd'hui
c'était pas cool
et puis et puis écoute ben à bientôt
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion de de
se revoir bientôt et sinon merci à tous
au chat tout ça à très bientôt en ce qui
me concerne moi je reprends le stream à
partir de lundi sur ma chaîne donc ma
chaîne je vais faire un petit peut-être
tu veux faire un petit saut
donc à priori voilà je reprends lundi le
string c'était un moment que j'ai pas
streamé parce que j'ai eu le tata style
qui m'a pris beaucoup de temps après je
suis parti en vacances en France à Nice
etc du coup du coup voilà demain lundi
on reprend le stream
et tout ça dans ma question pour Fatou
en même temps que souffle
en vrai je ne sais pas mais c'est très
probable que que j'ouvre bientôt
c'était pas loin quand même
ça fait quand même un moment que Fatou
on la pousse à stream et du coup ça cool
qu'elle sa chaîne bon en tout cas
bon en tout cas merci à tous
vraiment c'était vraiment super moi je
vous dis du coup ben à très bientôt et
puis un très bon week-end à vous et puis
ben reposez-vous bien à bientôt
comment
merci à tous ce fut un plaisir et ceux
qui sont sur Youtube n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à nous rejoindre sur
YouTube sur twitch
yes et ceux qui sont sur twitch aussi
n'hésitez pas à follow si ça vous a plu
que cetera je vous dis à très bientôt on
va lancer le raid et je vous dis à très
très bientôt bon weekend à tous ciao
ciao
bisous bisous